N-n-n-n-n-nice!
N-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-out
Ich hab nix großartig geplant, irgendwie was wir jetzt machen.
Ich hab gedacht, ich mach jetzt einfach mal Stream an, weil morgen früh ist ja wieder
ganz normal.
Sonntagliche Aufwachstream, aber ich war jetzt ein paar Tage nicht ordentlich, mir kommt
Samstag abends, wo die normalen Leute irgendwas machen, da hocke ich mich mal voll rechner.
Ich mein, was heißt normalen Leute, die sind auch nicht normal, wer ist schon normal im
Endeffekt?
Eigentlich ist keiner normal, alle haben so irgendeinen Dachschaden, mal mehr oder weniger
ausgeprägt.
Wie laut die Musik, hä?
Das ist, das ist Bomb on Battlefield Soundtrack, wusste gar nicht, dass das Remixed war in
Mario Galaxy.
Ach doch!
Da gab's doch!
In Mario Galaxy gab's doch genau, da gab's doch dieses Remake von dem zweiten Mario
64 Level.
Ich erinnere mich.
Mario Galaxy ist mein Lieblings-Mario-Game, nicht wirklich mit Abstand, aber schon klar
zu erkennen auf dem ersten Platz.
Mario Galaxy finde ich jetzt das Beste, obwohl es bei weitem nicht das erste Mario Game
ist, was ich gespielt habe.
Normalerweise ist es ja immer so, dass die Sachen, die man als allererstes ausprobiert,
auch die sind, wo man sagt, oh ja, beste Ever, aber, nee.
Also ich muss sagen, mein Lieblings-Mario, also ich muss sagen, mein Lieblings-Mario
ist ein Deutsch, Mario Galaxy und danach Mario 64, weil das mein erstes 3D-Mario war.
Super Mario World dahinter, weil ich das als allererstes gespielt habe.
Jetzt hast du in der Quarantäne was zu tun, oh, hast du Corona.
Keine Viewer, ja, das ist halt, wenn es kein Stream gibt.
Monka, Monka, Corona, kein Sub, auch keine 33 Monate, Massive, Hyper-Subscription hier.
Danke für den Sub, doch, wie gesagt, ich habe in Super Mario World angefangen damals,
aber ich muss sagen, im Nachhinein betrachtet, fand ich Mario 64 besser, als, vor allem,
wenn man sich überlegt, wie gut das war für die erste 3D-Sache, die sie je probiert haben,
aber Mario Galaxy war für mich so die Krönung des 3D-Marios, aber der erste, der erste Teil.
Ja, Yoshi's Island war auch mega nice generell, also ich muss sagen, die beiden Teile auf
dem Super Nintendo waren wirklich poc. Ja, wahrscheinlich, jetzt muss man das auch nicht
mal spielen. Ich glaube, man fährt mit den neueren dann schon besser, wenn man das damals
nicht gespielt hat und nicht gerade krasser Speed-Runner ist. Java für Java-Haters in
100 Sekunden, oh Sekunde, das müssen wir uns gleich angucken. Java für Java-Haters, naja,
gibt es, gibt es, gibt es auch Java-Enjoyer? Chat, haben wir Java-Enjoyer? Wahrscheinlich
haben wir auch Java-Enjoyer. Danke für die Subs-Leute hier, I gamble C++, ja, natürlich,
was sonst. Äh, Esor, vier Monate. Ne, ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass der, dass der durchschnittliche
Java-Enjoyer Giga-Chat ist. Ja, das kann ich auch verstehen, aber Java-Enjoyen verstehe
ich nicht. Was ist denn das Gegenteil von Giga-Chat, Leute? Ihr müsst mir ein bisschen Meme-Nachhilfe
geben. Also ich mein, guck mal, Zoomer und Boomer. Ne, das ist nicht, das ist nicht
Giga-Chat. Was ist das, was ist das Gegenteil von Giga-Chat? Java-Falle. Tja, kann man nichts
machen. Danke für den Sub, elf Monate. Fast gleich, gleich nächsten Monat hast du den
Gold-Kicks. Also anscheinend gibt es nicht so wirklich das Gegenteil von Giga-Chat. 480
FPS, way too much. Na dann, wenn es way too much ist, kann man nichts machen. Übrigens,
Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen. Ich habe meine Unraid-Kiste fertig gebaut heute. Also
im Prinzip ist die ja schon fertig, also sprich das, was wir im Stream zusammen gemacht haben,
plus dass ich jetzt endgültig mal alles draufgehauen habe, was drauf muss und aktuell, aktuell
ersüngt er gerade die Festplatte, den Nass-Inhalt rüber. Weil ich habe da zwei 10TB-Platten
drin. Ja, aktuell ersüngt er gerade und wahrscheinlich braucht er eine Weile. Was passiert heute?
Nix steht auch im Titel. Gar nichts. Jeder ist irgendwo Giga-Chat, ja in irgendeinem
Bereich wahrscheinlich. Ja, bei der aktuellen Inflationsrate, irgendwo muss ja ein bisschen
Gold und Geld drin sein. Und wenn es hier nur auf Twitch ist, aktuell wird unser Geld
ja immer nur weniger. Und das bleibt wahrscheinlich auch in absehbarer Zeit erstmal so. Schweizer
Franken, Alter. Patrick hat es gut. Pock, Pruschner, 10 Monate, danke schön für den
Sub. Ja, genau. Und ich musste mich zum ersten Mal damit beschäftigen, was der Kram überhaupt
kostet. So. Und ihr kennt meinen Hang dazu, bei sowas immer Pro- und Premium-Versionen
zu kaufen, aber ich habe mir nur die Basic-Version geholt, weil ganz ehrlich, man kann das wahrscheinlich
easy upgraden und wozu? Bestes Angebot, das finde ich immer geil. Pro, bestes Angebot.
Das ist so wie bei Werbung, die es teilweise gibt. Habe ich heute Mittag auch wieder irgendwas
gehört. Ja, ich mache manchmal eine Radio-App an, wenn ich Mittag esse. Habe ich auch wieder
eine Werbung gehört. Ab 400 Euro Kaufpreis gratis dazu, wo ich mir denke, also irgendwie
haben die andere Definition von gratis als ich. Also wenn ich denen schon 400 Euro geben
muss, dann ist das nicht gratis. Ich habe denen 400 Euro gegeben. Ja, wenn du mehr als
12 Geräte dran hast, dann macht es natürlich Sinn. Aber aktuell, ich habe aktuell zwei
S-Platten drin und eine SSD. Also, wozu? Es ist auch nicht teuer. Ja. Das ist Lizenz
für immer, soweit ich weiß. Also, was heißt für immer? Für immer für den USB-Stick.
Die sind gebunden an die Hardware-ID von deinem USB-Stick. Soweit ich das verstanden habe.
Erstmal Milch-Schnitte ballern. Ja, mach das mal. Man kann es übertragen. Ja, wäre auch
blöd, wenn nicht. Ja, ich muss da mal gucken. Aber aktuell, ich habe mir extra ein paar
Gescheite. War übrigens auch Tipp vom Chat. USB-Stick. Der Chat hat gesagt, die taugen.
Die da, glaube ich. Nein, das sind die falschen. Ich weiß nicht mehr, welchen USB-Stick. Ich
habe mir den USB-Stick auf Chat-Empfehlung gekauft. Und durch die ganzen Prime-Sub sozusagen
auch auf Chat-Snacken, wie man so schön sagt, heutzutage. Auch wenn ich es mega bescheuert
finde. Ich finde den jetzt gar nicht. Gibt es den gerade nicht mehr? Gibt es irgendwie
USB-Stick-Engpässe? Kann das sein? Ja, der eine. Aber ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie finde
ich den nicht mehr. Den ich habe. Der Chat hat ihn mir empfohlen. Was habe ich denn hier
noch in meinem Einkaufskorb? Zeig mal kurz. Habe ich nicht irgendwas vergessen? Mikro-SD
512G. Nein, ganz bestimmt nicht. Der Flux-Pen. Der Mini-Fluxer. Stimmt. Ich wollte mir ein
Stift holen für neues Flussmittel. Wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Kunstharz? Nein, wie heißt
das? Der heißt Flussmittel. Ist fürs Löten ganz praktisch. Wollte ich mir wieder ein
Stift holen. Sollte ich mal machen. Habe ich immer noch nicht gekauft. Kann ich richtig
empfehlen? Ja, die mag ich auch nicht. Das sind ja USB-Sticks, die quasi im Slot verschwinden.
Die da, die kleinen, die mag ich auch nicht. Moin. Ockchamp. Sebaro hat, was ist das? Sebaro,
der Cute-Mod. Ist der auch mal wieder da. Eine Mikro-SD-Karte für 60 Euro. 512G. Ja,
aber, also für was? Für Fotos? Ja, okay. Aber für Raspberry Pi und sowas ist doch komplett
unsinnig. Raspberry Pi brauchen, was weiß ich, wenn du es mit Mikro-SD-Karte betreiben
willst, dann nimm eine 32G, die ist billig als Fuck. Und ansonsten nimm irgendeine günstige
SSD und fertig. Diese Tab-Anzahl. Moment, Moment, Moment. Das heißt diese Tab-Anzahl.
Das muss so sein. Ich schließe keine Tabs. Irgendwo. Irgendwo für müssen doch die 32G
gut sein, oder? Stellt euch mal vor, ich habe 32GB RAM und benutze sie nicht. Das ist
doch rausgeschmissenes Geld. Felby, danke für den Zapp. Ja, kann man auch nehmen. Wenn
du einfach eine SATA-SSD nimmst, die ist von Raspberry Pi mehr als schnell genug, da geht
es eher um die Haltbarkeit, weil die deutlich haltbarer sind als Mikro-SD-Karten. Und dann
einfach einen billigen USB zu SATA-Adapter nehmen. Das Genre, das ist irgendeine, das
ist eine Plane. Top 50 Mario Songs of All Time. Ja, mittlerweile. Nein, habe ich noch nicht
gesehen. Können wir nachher gucken? Habe ich sogar auf irgendwo. Ja, also seit dem Raspberry
Pi 4 und der neuesten in Kombination, also was heißt nicht seit, mit dem Raspberry Pi
4 und seit ein paar Raspberry Pi OS Versionen geht das sogar standardmäßig. Also man muss
keine komischen Bootloader-Tricks mehr machen, dass das funktioniert und nicht vorher mal
installieren und dann rüber kopieren. Man kann jetzt direkt quasi auf die SSD sein, Raspberry
Pi OS drauf kopieren und direkt anstöpseln und es funktioniert. 2K Tabs, ja so. So viele
habe ich noch nicht. Ich würde sagen, ich habe ungefähr 100 oder so gerade. Nee, wenn
ich das mache, dann ist da alles weg. Das wäre ja blöd. Das wäre ja blöd. Ich brauche
das ja alles, was da auf ist. Naja, nicht wirklich, aber was habe ich da eigentlich
alles für einen Mist auf hier noch? Guckt euch das mal an. Noch irgendwelche LinkedIn-Dinger.
LinkedIn FAQ, was ist denn das? Wait a minute, was ist denn da? Ach, das ist der LinkedIn,
der LinkedIn Programmier-Dings-Test. Wait a minute, es gibt ein LinkedIn-Test zu After-Effects?
Okay, oder auch nicht. Zu Angular? Zu Angular, was gibt es, war mir klar. Bash, zu Bash?
Okay, Bash machen wir nachher, Leute, Bash. Beste. Was ich für einen Scheiß auf habe,
Alter. Wobei, das ist echt gut. Ich erinnere mich, es hat irgendjemand mal im Chat gepostet,
aber echt gut. You have the right to remain silent. Impossible, I'm an Arch-User, by the
way. Das ist geil. Was habe ich denn hier alles für einen Shit auf? Ah ja, Buch. Wo
wollte ich gar nicht hin. Wo haben wir es denn jetzt hier? Bash? Ach, da, da. Das machen
wir nachher. Nachher machen wir den Bash-Test. Leute, wir können auch gleich den, Leute,
wir machen gleich den Bash-Test. Easy. Also, welche dieser drei Methoden wird das Verzeichnis
Fotodire Recursive kopieren aus dem User-Home-Directory? Okay, das, das ist schon mal blöd. Was will
der machen? Also, CP minus R ist definitiv schon mal gut. Ich erkenne hier keinen Unterschied.
Ah, der Slash, ja klar, das da, das da, das da. Das untere ist es, weil tilde ist quasi
alias fürs Home-Verzeichnis, aber es muss tilde slash sein, sonst funktioniert das
nicht. Ne. Auf der anderen Seite, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das mit den Quotes
nicht aufgelöst wird, bevor es zum, wobei das ist egal. Das, wobei, hm, ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob nicht vielleicht sogar beide geht. Beides geht, also das untere geht auf
jeden Fall. Aber ne, das funktioniert nicht. Das geht nicht, weil der setzt hier dann Heimatverzeichnis
ein und dann sucht er nach explizit nem Ordner, der Slash-Fotodire heißt, aber, ne, ne, das
geht nur, das dritte, also. Okay. Bam, wir haben recht, nice. If script-sh is run in
the current directory, it will fail. Why? Okay. For, i, in, ls, sternchen, du, mv, dollar,
ah, bash, alter. Ah, weil Leerzeichen drin sind. Weil Leerzeichen drin ist. Weil der Standard
Input-Separator in bash ist Leerzeichen, Tab und Newline, glaub ich, und der würde versuchen,
beach, beach umzubenennen nach beach.buck, was sich funktioniert. Ja. Ls cannot access
nonexistent file. Ja, das, das, the loop will, ja, genau, das ist das, das ist das Problem.
Das ist der Song aus dem Wüstenlevel. Äh, musst du mal gucken, also das ist die Playlist.
Ihr könnt mal gucken, Song 39, ja, ich weiß nicht, was denn Song 39, 20, ne. So, okay,
aber das, das ist es hier, check, bam, wir haben recht, zack. To run a command, what's
to run a copy command in a sub-share, which syntax should be used. Äh, das da, weil das
da, also, also, man kann beides ausführen, aber nur das hier lässt es in einer sub-share
laufen, das hier ist quasi nur kopieren von commands, also das da. Ähm, klammer, klammer
geht in dem Fall nicht. Was genau meinen die mit sub-shell, ähm, dass deine shell, eine
weitere shell start, in der das kommando ausführt und dann den text dort einsetzt. So, check,
bam. Using awk, what should the output of this, oh Gott, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Der macht kein, please.
Kein awk-shit, alter. Jetzt, jetzt, über, über 23, was ist das für eine Frage? Echo
6? 6? Ich glaube AWK konkertet keine Strings. Ich glaube der rechnet direkt mit Zahlen.
ich glaube ich glaube das ist zu dumm ich glaube ich glaube der rechnet immer der
rechnet immer int aber es könnte auch da ich glaube aber es ist 6 ja
command below will search root files for files named finance db what information is being sent
to def null also find slash name flash ok standard out results standard error nach def null also
der error wird nach also sollte es fehler geben beziehungsweise solche sachen wie not found und
so dann ist es im error ok das auf jeden fall ne so das hier genau ok permanent
remove empty lines from a file called text file which command could you use boah das da das da
das weiß ich das war ja ach nee moment das da das da minus i minus i tb das ist tb das
ist das ist fies es ist das es ist das einser das ist tb und wisst ihr wisst ihr warum das
tb ist wisst ihr warum das tb ist weil es in dem fall um das minus i als parameter geht minus
i ist in place und bedeutet dass er dass er die datei direkt ändert hier ändert die datei nicht
direkt hier ändert er standard out nur nicht nicht den innerhalb der datei und warum geht das untere
nicht das untere macht aus ne ne ne das funktioniert minus d muss es sein für die li das da ist es ja
alter die was ist mit den los warum warum awk man ich mach ich mach gefühlt alle schalltiare noch
was mit awk wenn es wenn die sachen so kompliziert sind dass ich mit ein paar bestingern ein bisschen
cut und und tr und und last und hat und so nicht zurechtkomme dann bastel ich das in
irgendeiner ordentlichen programmier sprache anstatt da mich mit awk abzumühen wobei awk die
einzige sache wofür awk wirklich cool ist ist wenn du command outputs hast wo du nicht genau
weißt sind die felder jetzt leerzeichen sind die felder jetzt tabs awk ist ein kommando zeilen
programm unter linux also eigentlich ist es eine komplette eigene scripting sprache zum text
manipulieren aber niemand versteht mehr also wir nehmen an die user eins existiert also was
ist die ausgabe hiervon ich weiß ja nicht mal was minus f doppelpunkt macht wahrscheinlich
separator oder sowas viel separator oder sowas ich habe keine ahnung was minus f bei awk macht
tatsächlich viel separator habe ich habe ich recht gehabt nice ok also doppelpunkt also
schlecht user eins slash print dollar eins minus dollar drei ok boah ey keine ahnung
welcher reinfolge die sachen der pass wieder drinne stehen da steht als erstes soll auf was
in der pass mit drin usernahme nee sollt ne moment es sollt in shadows was steht in pass
mit drinne log in shell usernahme aktiviert nicht aktiviert was weiß ich das weiß ich
aus dem kopf was drinstehen welche reinfolge moin cheesy pro v2 info show username uid in
home directory ja ok uid group id it will print uid common use home directory ich hab
ehrlich gesagt keinen lassen schimmer was es davon ist das steht alles in der pass mit
drinne ich hab keine ahnung check ok bis das vierte what happens if we use the set minus
e das ist dass das kript abkackt beim ersten error schauen wir mal it will cause best it
will cause best to exit if a function or subsets ja non zero status code ja genau weil in
bash in bash muss man wissen in bash ist null ok und alles nicht null nicht ok weil
also was moment it will cause best exit if a function returns a non zero status code
nee das da ich boah das so genau so spezifisch weiß ich jetzt gar nicht ich sag mal das
vierte wenn der command fehl schlägt aber genau wissen dass so genau weiß ich das
doch nicht beim easy easy wie lang geht denn das überhaupt noch also 73 was
nee das mache ich nur 73 nee nee nee so weit nein nein so weit mache ich nicht garantiert
nicht wir machen best wir machen bis 15 oder so das reicht nee nee nee ich mach nicht bis
73 also underscore keyword pause ist das ernsthaft underscore key ach nee das soll man einsetzen
get argument read read gibt es read gibt es ja ja read gentle eddie ich hab keine ahnung
aus dem kopf ich weiß so grob was die dinger machen aber doch so im detail würde ich halt
einfach nachgucken if es ist feil sql holt sql zu bx und wat will be in feil der least
feil punkt sql ein und schreibt die ausgabe von von mysql wieder zurück also die ausgabe
von mysql in feil non error output of mysql command genau check nee er drei wäre
zwei zwei umleitungen oder es gibt ja ha man kann die ganze sache jetzt noch mal extra kompliziert
machen warum kann man das eigentlich nicht kopieren was ist das mysql also feil feil
punkt sql feil punkt txt so das hier ist redirect standard out das hier ist redirect
error out und die bash variante und ist redirect standard out und error out normalerweise hätte
müsste man schreiben und das weiß ich aus dem kopf jetzt gar nicht wie ist die andere
schreibweise und eins irgendwie so das kriege ich aus dem kopf gar nicht hin ich kenne
nur die bash variante also so wenn so wenn du beides umleiten willst weil kann sich
keine sau merken aber aber so ist das halt in bash und was ist mit vier
mir gar nicht sicher ob das nicht sogar auch funktioniert weil du kannst ja du kannst
ja prinzipiell mehrere sachen haben du hast halt deshalb zwei weil standard error out
das zweite zweite zweite output ist ich weiß ich ob es drei und vier gibt potenziell
kannst das geben aber ich weiß nicht ob bash das checkt aha gentle addys das habe ich
glaube ich noch nie gemacht es gibt doch nur drei streams muss aber nicht sein du könntest
theoretisch auch mehr anlegen hau das ok hau das so it or set you are the effect executable
commands das ist doch mit ich kann root werden nee ich kann als andere user das weiß ich
aus dem kopf jetzt alter ok also das haben wir zur auswahl wenn das commando files erzeugt
dann gehören sie als owner dem gruppen owner nee nee nee nee nee anyone to execute command
no matter nee command is executed it's running privileged elevate to the user owner of when
the command is executed it runs privileged to the user owner ja ja genau ich glaube das
ist es ich glaube das ist es wenn du das kommandos ausführst dann läuft es als der als der owner
also nicht als der eingemeldete user sondern als der owner der gesetzt ist auf dem kommando
ich glaube das ist drei in order to extract text from the first column of a file called
text file which command would you use hätt achso nee was ist creepy spoda musik luigi's
mansion in order to extract text from the first column of akkord also erste spalte awk würde
auf jeden fall funktionieren also das das geht auf jeden fall ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob awk selbst an der stelle überhaupt input erlaubt kat minus d wird auch funktionieren
ja ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das so funktioniert oder ob man das bei awk hinten dran schreiben
muss es ist auf jeden fall nicht gequoted das wird schon mal mit awk nicht funktionieren
also muss es das hier sein ja neues von battlefield ey wartet mal leute wir müssen mal reingucken
ok es ist genauso scheiße wie sonst new world mal kurz angucken new world wird immer wird
immer schlechter aber ich habe letztens auf twitter und twitter battlefield coms die haben
sich wieder komplett komplett lächerlich gemacht sie haben letztens einen post raus
gehauen hier zu ihrem core feedback das ist ja das wo sie versprochen haben so nach dem
motto wir hören jetzt auch wirklich auf die spieler du guckst gerade alle meine videos
das ist nice das aber ganz schön was zu tun ich würde mir selbst nicht mehr alle meine
videos angucken vor allem die alten teilweise ein bisschen cringe was ich da so erzähle
aber ok so was ich ja lustig finde das game ist ein halbes jahr draußen ungefähr und
was den jetzt einfällt ist passt mal auf wir könnten die flaggen vielleicht anders positionieren
auf unseren maps könnte das sein dass unsere maps scheiße sind ein halbes jahr nach release
das ist so zum fremd schämen diese ganze alles was mit battlefield 2042 zu tun hat
das ist absolut lächerlich komplett lächerlich ich werde ein halbes jahr nach release es
ist nicht so dass die jetzt dass die jetzt gesagt hätten es ist nicht so dass die jetzt
gesagt hätten jungs patch ist raus die maps sind alle gefixt und gut spielbar nein nein
nein nein das ist ein das ist ein blog post über einen theoretischen change den man vielleicht
machen könnte in battlefield 2042 um die maps in zukunft besser spielbar zu machen die
sache ist plus die spielbar werden die maps nie sein weil es ist keiner mehr da das spielt
das ist das ist das ist so lächerlich dieser ganze laden außerdem ist eh das nächste battlefield
in entwicklung und es passiert im prinzip das was ich quasi schon zwei wochen nach release
gesagt habe die werden das absolut mindestmaß liefern und kein finger mehr krumm machen
richtig für das game so soll jetzt aussehen naja die können nicht alle einen refund geben
das game hat jetzt schon nicht wirklich viel kohle gemacht oder gar keine kohle gemacht
keine ahnung wenn jetzt wenn die alle leuten ein refund geben wollen weil das geht immer
richtig ins geld ganz schnell wurde heute wieder vorgeschlagen
leute ihr werdet es mir nicht glauben aber ich war heute im freien guckt mal
ihr könnt euch das gar nicht vorstellen war heute im freien und es ist muss man mal sagen
ziemlich ziemlich viel winter obwohl es nicht winter ist heute gewesen
kaos meck was ist was ist das das subreddit sagt mir nichts und ich kann das jetzt hier
nicht öffnen
soll das sein
plays ist super man kann jeden
user kann alle fünf sekunden einen pixel auf der canvass platzieren das ist sowas wie
alle malen zusammen da kommt doch bestimmt tos zeug raus was macht das logo in der taste
das ist ein terminal das ist ja eigentlich wirklich das logo sondern das lambda zeichen
aber es passt ja das kann ich mir vorstellen wenn du gewissest die kirche immer sehr viel
habe ich gehört das etc passt alle die defender die fender triggert bei uns ja schon automatisch
aktuell wenn du den ram verbrauch anguckst den musst du gar nicht triggern da triggert
schon von ganz allein
nicht so viel tos kann man ruhig zeigen na ich weiß ja nicht ja ich habe reingeguckt
kann man kann man wohl tatsächlich zeigen so hat mir die battlefield geschichte auch
abgehakt und irgendjemand meinte er hat letztens mein erstes video gesehen mein erstes video
würde ich mir heute nicht mehr angucken die soundqualität war so dermaßen schlecht leute
hört euch das mal an ich halte es nicht aus ich also ich cringe da jetzt schon nur wir
hören uns nur die ersten drei setze an ja so schlecht ist die soundqualität doch gar
nicht dafür gibt es einen erfolg ist cool wusste ich auch noch nicht ich habe das mikrofon
so krass im mond stecken gehört hört euch das mal an ein bisschen gameplay zeigen ich
habe ich habe das mikrofon ist ja schlimm ist ja schlimm 208.000 views er hat 2010 da
gab es nicht so viel gameplay videos auf youtube also ich habe gesagt headset gamer headset
mache ich versprochen ganz klasse ganz wunderbar kann man selbst nicht angucken das geht nicht
an tun ok noch zwei bestfragen leute noch zwei bestfragen sind wir bei 15 das reicht
also keyboard shortcut to call a basis research as a control er kontrol er history search das
wichtigste was man wissen muss wenn man linux auf der kommando zeile benutzt ist kontrol
er das ist das wichtigste das das aller allererste kontrol er ok vielleicht feil hoch feil runter
davor aber bevor man irgendwas anderes macht kontrol er weil wir wissen in aktuellen in
aktuellen zeiten wo niemand mehr was dokumentiert weil man ja immer automatisch quasi fehlerfreie
perfekte sachen schreibt ist die history die beste dokumentation es gibt kontrol er und
die history size muss hochgestellt werden history size unlimited und dann einfach nachgucken
ist aber ich habe doch vor zweieinhalb jahren mal was eingetippt in der richtung kontrol
er tippen gut ist ja history grab kann man auch machen das funktioniert auch für ein
bisschen komplizierter ist außer bei zsh da muss man aufpassen da ist history glaube ich
limitiert schon einmal auf 100 oder so da musste er glaube ich eingeben minus n null
oder so ich verwende es so selten deine winnaustaste geht nicht mehr tja da gibt es zwei varianten
ich habe da ich habe da eine vermutung und zwar entweder ist deine winnaustaste kaputt
oder dein desktop ist zu voll get organized klick hier ein microsoft dazu kann ich nur
sagen piss dich also microsoft geht mir auf den sack mit ihrem komischen eingeblendet
da guck mal ob dein desktop so voll ist guck mal ob dein desktop so voll ist wenn nämlich
dein wenn nämlich dein desktop zu voll ist voller als meiner also ich rede hier von einem
desktop der quasi so sehr gefüllt ist dass er über den desktop hinausgeht dann backt
das startmenü manchmal also wenn du dein desktop so voll hast dass du quasi zwei drei desktops
damit füllen könntest dann dann leckt das startmenü beim öffnen teilweise das merkst
du wenn du es ganz oft hintereinander drückst und es unregelmäßig auf und zu geht das
ist ein bug den gibt schon seit frag mich nicht windows xp oder so der ist immer noch
da warum hast du quicktime installiert damit sony vegas moff files lesen kann warum auch
immer dieser standardmäßig nicht können ja das könnte natürlich auch sein aber das
müsste es dir dann wissen wenn das aktiviert hast so eine frage noch leute 2 2 ja 15 habe
ich sagen machen wir which areas das kann ich nicht aussprechen leute wie spricht man
das aus und arithmetic oder so wahrscheinlich nein arithmetic arithmetic alles klar which
arithmetic expression will give most will give the most precise answer arithmetic das
bc ist auf jeden fall ganz gut drin und ich glaube scale sind nachkommastellen expr könnte
auch sein also das sind auf jeden fall relativ sicher nur ins innerhalb ich probiere das
einfach mal aus check jawoll easy wup wup fatal dankeschön für den sub ok result of
this script txt gleich penguins penguins dollar txt gags geschiss also das hier ist das best
text quasi test ok dollar txt enthält wahrscheinlich sowas wie groß a bis z hintereinander 0 bis
8 das funktioniert nicht weil p ist groß geschrieben das heißt echo dollar fragezeichen
ist 1 weil in best ist 1 gleich hat nicht funktioniert quasi doch regex ist case sensitive
in dem fall weil es eine zeichengruppe ist und dass die zeichengruppe klein a bis klein
z also das ist falls genau falls because variable txt does not contain 8 lowercase characters
between 1 zack easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy so gut genug best gemacht
für heute es reicht ja aber in best ist das standardmäßig so zumal wenn du zeichengruppen
angibs angibs wäre es ziemlich bescheuert das case insensitiv zu machen weil wenn du
es case insensitiv machen willst da könntest du auch eine gruppe nehmen für sagen wir
mal alle characters oder sowas das sind das sind 73 fragen oder so insgesamt das machen
wir das machen wir jetzt nicht alles und jetzt regex ne ja power shell ist ja auch microsoft
graben da weißt du nicht so genau was sie treiben wo ist eigentlich das keksloh wo ist
das keksloh ich weiß nicht und wie funktioniert es jetzt muss man jetzt angemeldet sein oder
wie funs das chat wenn man angemeldet ist kann man da jetzt pixel alle fünf minuten
drauf platzieren oder wie da
stehe haben wir hier platz um noch ihren keks hin zu machen kein platz mehr leute hier unten
konnte man kopper das ist schon gelb das ist schon gelb die weeps sind natürlich auch
wieder am start was nicht alles gibt das artel logo ja warum dann artel logo ist es natürlich
kein schimmer warum das artel logo drin ist osu osu ist so ein rhythmus musik game mit
mit weep anime musik guck mal hier leute weiß nicht ob genug leute kriegen wir hier den
keksen ich bin überhaupt nicht in der lage irgendwie ordentlich zu machen ich glaube
das funktioniert nicht
der erfinder von osu streamt fast jeden tag hier auf twitch
klickt ihr da gerade drin rum chat
guck mal ein roter pixel da ist er skyfall riva schön dass du den weich her gefunden
hast chat das wird so nix ich guck nachher noch mal rein ob das was geworden ist aber
ich glaube nicht sind da viele bots dabei wahrscheinlich was ist mit dem preis jam
ja den gibt es nicht mehr der preis jam ist down leute der ist weg und der preis jam ist
weg weil der tracker nicht hinterher gekommen ist also die das upstream crawler projekt
war für deutsche shops zu langweilig wallpaper safari es gibt seiten die kling ich halt lieber
nicht an wer weiß was da abgeht
ergibt 30 90 hier für 2 o pock na gut mit 30 prozent inflationsrate oder so kostet es
bald jedes doppelte
das ist immer ich habe das das sind so trends die gehen voll an mir vorbei reddit plays
haben wir uns schon die battlefield spielerzahl angesehen ja guck sie siehst du das etwa
moment das ist cyberpunk siehst du das etwa nicht hier guck da ist das tab für battlefield
erkennt man doch
ja die spielerzahlen sind wie gewohnt schlecht und oh leute stonks
was ist da los huge massive das geht ja nach oben hier jetzt hält sie nichts mehr auf überlegt
ihr mal überlegt ihr mal wenn es jeden monat ein prozent wächst dann sind wir ja quasi
in zwei jahren quasi sonst wo da sind wahrscheinlich die spots oder so die wollen dass es da wieder
grün ist gut realistisch betrachtet muss man halt sagen es sind 19 muss ich das mal
man muss sich das mal wirklich in zahlen auf der zunge zergehen lassen 19 spieler 19 bei
einem neuen battlefield spiel die dazu 19 das sind nicht 19 prozent oder so das sind
19 spieler im durchschnitt mehr
wie weekend keine ahnung das ist so so so so schlecht
es ist einfach der wahnsinn ja peak players ist exakt gleich na gut die 19 spieler haben
reingeguckt haben sie gesagt gut 19 spieler durchschnitt bedeutet ja in wirklichkeit es
sind mehr spieler weil 19 sind immer permanent eingeloggt aber trotzdem
lächerlich
gut lächerlich was da was da abgeht
was trinken hydrated stain
ja
viel besser
zum thema youtube spam comments youtube needs to fix this ja das müssen wir auch ohne video
das finde ich auch richtig beknackt es ist so viel dummer spam auf youtube aktuell
ist so mit dem digital führerschein fertig ja den haben wir das letzte mal durchgeklickt
aber dann hat sie die seite nicht gespeichert
wahnsinn
in zehn jahren hoffen die wahrscheinlich dass niemand mehr auch nur entfernt daran
denkt dass es mal battlefield 2042 überhaupt gegeben hat
ok
da ist schreck leute warum ist da seht ihr ihn
da ist schreck guckt mal
schreck war das die challenge
so
nehmen das mal als wallpaper ich habe selbst genug auf dem desktop da brauche ich das nicht
noch als hintergrund haben
aber ich finde es eine gute idee ich ich speichere mir das ich speichere mir das mal
das ist doch auch nur der gleiche ausschnitt immer copy pasted oder guckt mal das hier
ist immer wieder da
dieses eigen ist immer wieder da das da ist immer wieder da
und hier sind auch immer die gleichen internet explorers auch immer da
damit kannst du beweisen dass du weißt wo was ist inwiefern
das gibt es denn eigentlich jetzt noch spannendes was wollte ich mir für ein video angucken
haben wir doch eben gesagt das da ja war vor haters gibt es na gut wir haben ja vorhin
gefragt es gibt tatsächlich java enjoyer und jemand meinte java enjoyer gleich giga
chat und dann muss ich widersprechen das wirklich leichte anmaßung hier übertreibung
so java vor haters100 sekunden
Java
Aja, richtig
Ja, Sun ist ja Geschichte, es ist ja Oracle
Mittlerweile, Sun ist ja schon seit 10 Jahren weg vom Fenster
Alter, der Kerl sieht so fertig aus
Das stimmt wohl wirklich, die Webseite sieht wirklich aus wie 1995
Guckt euch das mal an
Ich mein, immerhin
Aber, was ist das hier?
Die Webseite hat wirklich keiner jemals wieder aktualisiert
Ein Moment, es gibt ja Log4j, gab's ja
Und dann gab es Log4shell
Und jetzt gibt es ja
Was ist das?
Spring4shell oder sowas?
Moment, wo hat Heise da nicht was drüber gebracht?
Ja, das hier
Spring4shell gibt's jetzt
Log4shell ist aus, Spring4shell ist angesagt
Ich fange am ersten Nacht meine Ausbildung an
Ist ja nicht mal weit hin, ist ja nur 4 Monate
Dann geht's los
Hab dein Video über deine Berufsschule gesehen
Ich muss auch, du musst auch an die Werder von Siebert Schule in Frankfurt
Viel Spaß
Ganz ehrlich
Die Berufsschule ist nicht schlechter als andere Berufsschulen
Die sind alle so scheiße
Ansonsten
Du darfst einfach nichts erwarten von der Schule
Geh da hin
Und betrachte es als
Zeit in der du quasi
Nicht arbeiten musst und trotzdem Geld verdienst
Oder sowas in der Richtung
Also ich fand Berufsschule immer gut
Aber nicht weil ich die Berufsschule gut fand
Sondern weil es im Prinzip 3 Wochen am Stück Entspannung war
Vielleicht ist sie jetzt besser als vor 20 Jahren
Glaubt irgendjemand, dass es jetzt besser ist als vor 20 Jahren?
Nee
Außer bis jetzt 15 Jahre her
Werner von Siemans Schule Frankfurt
Die Bewertungen sprechen doch für sich, oder?
Also die Bewertungen sprechen doch wirklich für sich
Neueste
Schauen wir doch mal
Seit wann ist das nicht mehr im Fullscreen?
Wie macht man Bewertungen im Fullscreen auf, Leute?
Äh
Hey
Da ist endlich mal ein Bild von innen
Diese Schule sieht aus wie der Knast, Alter
Guckt euch das mal an
Wie im Gefängnis sieht das aus
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn, das Ding
Ähm
Wie kann man denn jetzt nochmal Bewertungen im Fullscreen aufmachen?
Geht das nicht mehr?
Oder muss man das dann über Maps aufmachen, dass es im Fullscreen war?
Ach, was auch immer
Wie kann man es jetzt sortieren nach neueste?
Also, was sagt er denn hier?
Recht verwinkelte Gebäudestruktur, man kann sich leicht verlaufen, ja, das stimmt
Ich glaube, ich hab nach 2,5 Jahren Berufsschule Sachen immer noch nicht gefunden
Ja, man kann sich wirklich leicht verlaufen, das ist auch wahnsinnig unübersichtlich, das Ding
Nachdem man hier noch einige Zeit dort war, findet man, naja, ich hab mich nie richtig zurecht gefunden
Die Qualität des Unterrichts lässt aber teils zu wünschen übrig, ja, der war kottenschlecht
Am besten fand ich immer noch
Als mein damaliger
Das war BWL?
Oder ich weiß nicht mehr wie das war, was ist BWL, Leute?
LF Lernfach 4?
Kann das sein?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, im BWL Unterricht habe ich Mario Kart gespielt, auf dem DS immer
Mit einem Kollegen in der Berufsschule
Und einmal hatte ich das Ladekabel dran und der Lehrer ist über mein DS-Ladekabel gestolpert
LF 4 ist Elektrotechnik, okay
Ah, da weiß ich nicht mehr, was BWL ist, LF 8 oder so
Der Lehrer ist über das DS-Kabel gefallen
Okay, die Qualität des Unterrichts lässt über, ja
Man wird nicht auf die Prüfung vorbereitet
Was hat der Lehrer gesagt?
Der Lehrer hat gesagt, ups, sorry
Und dann hat er sich umgedreht und dann hat er gesagt, Max, spielst du DS?
Und ich habe gesagt, ja
Sonst konnte ich ja nicht verstecken werden
Das hat ihm ja nicht so gefallen, aber okay
Was will er machen? Im Prinzip ist es denen da auch alles egal
Das juckt den überhaupt nicht
So, also nächstes Gebiet
Gebiet?
Weil ich im Chat gerade Katastrophengebiet gelesen habe, habe ich gesagt, Gebiet, Schwachsinn
Nächste Bewertung
Man wird sehr gut für die Zwischen- und Gesellenprüfung vorbereitet
Was ist da los?
Das glaube ich dem aber nicht
Meint die Musik ist aus
Ah, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ah, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Leute, ich finde nichts mehr
Uwu Auri hat bewertet
Uwu Auri, okay
Ich besuche diese Schule jetzt seit einem Jahr
Okay, von Sauberkeit ist dort recht wenig zu finden, das ist wahr
Die Schule ist dreckig als Fuck
Aber man muss sich auch mal angucken, wo diese Schule ist
Guckt mal, das hier ist die Gutleutstraße
Das ist eine ziemlich lange Straße in Frankfurt
Wo auch direkt am Hauptbahnhof vorbeigeht
Der Hauptbahnhof müsste hier sein
Hier ist der Hauptbahnhof und hier geht die Gutleutstraße vorbei unten
Und hier
Moment, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle
Aber hier ist die Polizeistation irgendwo, ne?
Irgendwo ist die Polizei
Hier musste ich mal, hier runter musste ich mal zur Polizei
Irgendwo ist hier Polizeirevier 4 oder so in Frankfurt
Ja, ich musste mal zum Polizeirevier 4 in Frankfurt
Weil mein Chef, mein damaliger Chef in der Ausbildung
Wurde abends am Hauptbahnhof überfallen
Ist kein Witz jetzt
Und dem haben sie sein Portemonnaie geklaut
Und ein paar Tage später
Haben sie die Typen aufgegriffen
Und haben sein Portemonnaie wiedergefunden
Und dann hat er mich während der Ausbildung
Quasi während der Arbeitszeit zur Polizeistation 4
Oder wie das Ding hieß, geschickt
Um sein Portemonnaie abzuholen
Da bekommt man richtig Bock
Hier
Frankfurt live, Alter
Nee, aber mach dir mal nichts draus
Du fährst eh vom Hauptbahnhof
Also du fährst wahrscheinlich auch zum Hauptbahnhof, ne?
Du musst dann hier raus
Und hier neben ist
Hier neben an der Seite stehen die Busse irgendwo
Irgendwo hier
Irgendwo hier sind die Bushaltestellen
Da steigst du morgens ein
Hier, hier ist der Bus
Da steigst du morgens ein und der hält direkt
Der hält direkt hier an der Schule
Also da passiert nichts
Musst dir keine Gedanken machen
Außer halt die ganzen Drogenabhängigen und Penner hier in der Ecke
Also hier generell so diese
Diese, diese Ecke hier
Niederstraße und alles
Das hier, Taunusstraße, Niederstraße hier oben
Diese, diese Ecke
Moselstraße
Diese Ecke hier, das ist ganz schlimm, Leute
Also hier wollt ihr in Frankfurt nicht hin
Diese Ecke
Das ist, das ist richtig
Richtig, aber
Kaiserstraße war früher übelst im Verruf
Weil da die ganzen Puffs waren
Heute sind, heute ist quasi kaum noch
Rotlicht auf der Kaiserstraße
Sondern Friseure und Dönerläden
Die haben im Prinzip
Die Puffs verdrängt
Wurdest du schon einmal dort bedroht
Also ich wurde noch nie
Überfallen
Bedroht schon
Ja, kann man das bedroht nennen
Ich hatte, ich sag mal so
Ich hatte schon meine
Auseinandersetzung mit Leuten
Auf der, auf der Straße in Frankfurt
Oder auch im McDonalds
Auf der, auf der Kaiserstraße, Alter
Also Zeit, dass ich da zu
Zu McDonalds gegangen bin
Aber bedroht in Form von
Überfallen wurde ich noch nie
Ja, melde dich mal September
Gut
So, wieviel UML-Diagrammen
Ich hab auf der Arbeit noch nicht ein UML-Diagramm gemalt
Ja, und, und ein Tipp
Für alle, die mal so am Hauptbahnhof sind
Man ist geneigt
Man ist geneigt, wenn man hier
Lang, lang kommt, gelaufen
Kommt, da
Man ist geneigt, unter der Straße
Durchzugehen, es gibt so eine
Es gibt ne Unterführung
Es gibt ne Unterführung, von hier
Und von hier
Zum Hauptbahnhof
Das kann man machen, das ist nicht
Schlimm, aber gerade die hier
Da hängen immer die ganzen Drogen
Abhängen mit Spritzen auf der Treppe ab
Da will man eigentlich nicht lang
Also, hinter der Rolltreppe
Hier ist die Rolltreppe und neben kann man dann
Raus und da stehen die alle
Hier würde ich nicht langlaufen
Was haben die eigentlich für Bewertungen
Hier bin ich ab und zu mal essen gegangen
Ich dachte, die impfen sich
Bestimmt, bestimmt
Das sind bestimmt illegale Corona-Impfungen
Vom Hauptbahnhof, ganz bestimmt, ja
Tja
Gibt es eigentlich
Gibt es eigentlich diesen
Diesen komischen
Laden neben der Berufsschule noch
Jetzt hab ich die Berufsschule
Hier unten ist die Berufsschule irgendwo
Äh, Sekunde, gehen wir mal kurz zurück
Hier, Werner von Simon Schule
So
Da war mal so ein komischer
Die Kantine
Pizza
Nee, das ist was anderes, das gibt's nicht mehr
Es gab hier früher so einen billigen
So einen billigen
Dönerladen, da hab ich mal Döner geholt
Eine übelst dünnsches danach
Was denk ich mehr
Komm, hier ist Ali A
Das könnte irgendein Rapper-Name sein
Egal, Frankfurt, Frankfurt
Leben, so ist es halt
Gut, aber ich wollt mir die Bewertung
Vor allem bei der Berufsschule mal schnell anschauen
Noch mal
Sekunde
Ali A
Ali S gibt's doch
Keine Ahnung, ich kenn mich
Im deutschen Hip-Hop-Business nicht aus
Sag mal
Das sind doch andere Bewertungen
Als eben noch, oder?
Guck mal, Gefängnis
Gefängnis hat fünf Tags
Gefängnis ist fünfmal getaggt worden an der Berufsschule
Sag mal
Das sind doch jetzt
Das sind doch andere Bewertungen als vorher
Ah
Ich hab vorher nicht gefiltert, nach neuestem
Ok, ok, ok, passt
Ah
Ich hab vorher nicht gefiltert, nach neuestem
Ok, ok, ok, passt
Ok, sehr gut
Sehr gut, alles klar
Vier Stunden Religion in einer Informatikschule
Ja
Ich glaub aber auch nur ein Jahr
Und das hat bei uns nie stattgefunden
Also unsere Religionslehrerin
Oder Ethiklehrerin, ich weiß nicht
Die war einmal da
Und hat dann gemeint, die kriegt einfach von mir alle eine zwei
Hab ich kein Problem mit
Das ist in Ordnung
Lehrer sind gut, aber Technik lässt zu wünschen
Übrigens, ok
Recht verwinkelte Gebäude, Struktur
Ah, das hatten wir grad schon
Ben Petermann
Sagt nix, Lehrerin ist super
Ja, das wundert mich nicht
Das wundert mich nicht
Das Toilettenpapier der oberen Toilettenkabine
War komplett vollgepisst
Das wundert mich nicht
Aufs Klo dürft ihr da auf gar keinen Fall gehen
Als
Kerl habt ihr es noch gut
Da könnt ihr aufs Klo
Da gibt es die guten alten Pisrennen
Aufs Klo setzen, im Leben nicht
Im Leben nicht
Ich habe zuerst gedacht, dass es ein umgebautes Gefängnis ist
Äh, die Männer sieht aus wie in einem schlechten...
Das stimmt, das stimmt
Die ähm
Das äh, der Kiosk
Und das davor sieht wirklich aus wie in einem Gefängnisfilm
Auch, du hast auch oben so
So
Aufseher
Übergänge und so
Das sieht wirklich wie im Knast aus
Die Toiletten sind eine Bio Gefährdung
Afk Arena am Start
Oh, er hat es gelöscht
Er hat bestimmt geflamet über Lehrer
Wenn er gesagt hätte
Das ist jetzt aber wieder so ein ganz
So ein Korinthenkacker hier
Wenn man sich das anguckt
Hätte der einen Ton gesagt
Hätte der gesagt
Ich will nicht, dass sie meine Noten
Vorlesen
Dann hätte er das auch nicht gemacht
Sein Vater ist Anwalt, genau
Und meine arbeitet bei Microsoft
Und band euch alle
Privacy
Ok
Was sagt der hier?
Sauberkeit ist deutsch recht wenig
Das ist wohl wahr, ja
Auf die Toiletten sammeln
Sich
Das ist mir nie aufgefallen
Ich bin aber eigentlich auch so gut wie nie
Aufs Klo gegangen
Das stimmt, die Lehrer sind zum größten Teil
Richtig mies
Überall veraltete Stühle
Die quietschen und knarren, ja
Kann ich bestätigen, war bei mir auch schon so
Tja, das habe ich mich damals
Auch schon gefragt
Ob sie immer noch Windows XP haben
Richtiger Saftladen
Ne, das stimmt nicht
Also er schreibt hier die Zeit, die ich dort verbracht habe
Hätte ich lieber im Betrieb verbracht
Nein, das nicht
Ich fand Berufsschule gut
Ich fand nicht die Berufsschule gut, die hier
Aber ich fand Berufsschule an sich gut
Weil es einfach
Nach 3 Wochen quasi Urlaub waren
Top
Corona, keine Corona
Das wundert mich nicht, dass sie da nichts umgesetzt haben
Ok, ok, gibt auch positive Meldungen
Alles klar
Schöne Lage
Aber ansonsten Schmutz
Hä?
Die meisten Lehrer machen nur Unterricht
Blätter und
Ja, das stimmt
Wir müssen euch mal die Fotos angucken
Guckt euch mal
Nur mal ganz kurz nochmal
Guckt euch mal die Fotos an
Von außen
Einfach irgendwelche
Random Matratzen und sowas
Das ist ein Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel
Das sieht halt nicht
Es ist nicht so, dass die ganze Welt
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel wäre ASI
Das ist auch wirklich so
Du bist auf
Ich war eben auf Plays
Irgendjemand wollte wissen, warum es da keinen Keks gibt
Das kann einfach, weil noch keiner gemalt hat
Oh man, diese Schule
Genug jetzt geguckt
Bilder
Ich wollte noch mal kurz schauen, ob es von innen vielleicht ein bisschen was gibt
Fotos ansehen
Wie gesagt, das Treppenhaus
Guckt euch die Wände da unten an, die sind nicht verputzt
Die Wände in der Schule
sind zum größten Teil nicht verputzt
Die sehen so aus wie da unten
Es ist wirklich wie im Knast
Auf dem Bild ist ein Overheadprojektor
Das wundert mich nicht
So modern sind wir nicht
Sieht aus wie Lost Places
Also in der Schule könnte man wirklich
Lost Places machen
Auf jeden Fall
Jeder, der schon mal in der
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof Region war, weiß, wie das da ist
Dabei muss man sagen, Frankfurt
hat richtig Geld
Und die machen ja auch relativ
viel
Also Frankfurt ist glaube ich, was
Einkünfte eingeht, eines der reichsten
Städte in Deutschland
Also die haben schon Geld
Die stecken ja auch einiges rein
Ich meine, die bauen jetzt ein komplett neues Stadtviertel
Früher vorbeigefahren, ja
Ja da fährt, wie gesagt,
Gutlohnstraße fährt man oft vorbei
So
Ja
Chat, was machen wir jetzt? Wir wollten irgendein YouTube-Video gucken
Ja, wahr
Wir haben das immer noch nicht fertig geguckt
Moment, ich habe das Video angefangen
und da einfach aufgehört zwischendurch
So was würde ich doch nie machen
Normalerweise, wie kommt das denn dazu?
Boah, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie der Name ist
Die bauen einen neuen Stadtteil
Oh, ich habe gerade meinen Arm angehauen
Angeblich
Für mehr Wohnraum
Mal gucken, ob es da auch Wohnungen gibt, die man bezahlen kann
Tja, das weiß ich auch nicht
Weil AWS teuer als fuck ist
Panos Viertel 2
Ja, ist ein guter Name
So, schauen wir mal
Java Video fertig gucken
Was wurde aus dem AWS in deiner Nähe?
Da bin ich letztens erst vorbeigelaufen
Nichts, keine Bauarbeiten und nichts
Bisher
Meinst du, dass man jemals was von Kabum hört?
Ich glaube, der ist mit YouTube durch
Java Applets
Moment, Sekunde
Wo habe ich das Passe?
Also das war eines der schlimmsten Sachen aller Zeiten
Java Applets, man
Java Applets waren die absolute Pest
Also
Ja, ich
Member das auch
Das war ganz schlimm
Schöne Swinguie
Es ist schlimmer Java Applet
oder Silverlight Java Applet
ist auf jeden Fall schlimmer
Silverlight ist gar nicht
so beschissen gewesen, fand ich vom Ansatz her
Ich bin aber erstens kein WPF-Freund
kein XAML-Freund
das ist Silverlight eh nie was für mich gewesen
Und das eigentliche Problem bei Silverlight
ist, dass Microsoft da nach kurzer Zeit schon keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte
Ansonsten war die Idee von Silverlight
und ansonsten vielfach angenehmer als Java
Public Static Void Main String Args
Gut, das ist in C Sharp auch so
Nur, dass du in C Sharp
diesen Scheiß mittlerweile weglassen kannst
und direkt hinschreiben
Oh, UML
Aber
als Java Programmierer muss man unbedingt
alles dann noch als UML machen
Weil richtig cool objektorientiert
kannst du nur mit UML
UML und dann am besten täglich
noch drüber mieten und zusammen das
Ding aus sich ausdenken
Das ist wohl wahr
aber
also bei C++
gibt es mindestens genauso viel zu complainen
wie bei Java
Ja, da hat er recht
Der Kram funktioniert
Prinzipiell wenigstens nicht so wie C++
Was vom Design her schon so beschissen ist
dass es eigentlich keinen mehr auf der Welt gibt
der den Kram überhaupt versteht
Also ich will keinen Monitor
der Alexa eingebaut hat
und ich will auch keinen Monitor
der einen SmartThings Hub eingebaut hat
Der Kerl
ist nicht mehr ganz dicht
Ich gucke mir die Videos von dem Öfters an
und ich finde die Heimautomatisierung Ideen
von ihm wirklich gut
Aber in einem Punkt ist er echt, meiner Meinung nach
nicht mehr ganz dicht
Der hat 30 verschiedene Hubs und Automatisierung
Da wirst du doch verrückt
Das ist auch nochmal nebenbei
Interview
mit einem Vim Enthusiast
Ok
Das müssen wir uns jetzt auch angucken
Vim ist aber mal richtig
für Only Hacker Mans
How to exit Vim Leute
Ja was fällt euch so ein?
Was
Was fällt euch, was fällt euch ein?
Also es gibt
mindestens vier Mainstream Varianten
Ku, Ku ist schon mal gut
Ich sehe hier den Profi
Ich habe ihn erkannt
X, X könnt ihr noch machen?
Das funktioniert auch
Leute
Eigentlich wollte ich hier drauf raus
Shift ZZ beziehungsweise ZZ
Das wissen die wenigsten
Ich habe keine Ahnung warum Shift ZZ
ein Ding ist in Vim
Warum das überhaupt eingebaut ist
Warum es geht
Wenigstens das du Shift ZZ machen kannst
Alter 4 kannst du bei einem grafischen Vim
unter Windows vielleicht machen
Oder lässt es wahrscheinlich
Temp Files übrig wenn du die nicht ausgestellt hast
Gibt es noch andere Shift Commands?
Fällt kein sein
Wahrscheinlich
Eins ist an Vim wirklich gut
Die Hilfe, man glaubt das kaum
Aber die Hilfe für Vim
ist wirklich
nicht schlecht
Passt mal auf
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz
Also eine Sache kann man Vim
wirklich nicht nachsagen und zwar dass sie schlechte Hilfe hätte
Guck mal
Machst du Vim auf?
Sagst Help Exit
Oder findest du
1000 Sachen
zu Exit
Es gibt auch
ZQ Guck mal haben wir da was gelernt
Dieses Github Repo hat
Dutzende Möglichkeiten Vim zu schließen
Jetzt wundert mich nicht dass es dazu ein eigenes Github Repo gibt
mit 5,8 Tausend Sternen
Wundert mich nicht
dass es das gibt
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Interview mit
einem Vim Enthusiast
Die Vim vs ID
Vergleich
Weißt du wie viel schneller Vim war?
4,3 Sekunden
4,3 Sekunden, das habe ich jeden Tag gebeten
All diese Monate Lernen waren total wert
GQ5UP
Das ist eigentlich der Modell meines Watchs
Vim oder VI
Oder was auch immer
Du nimmst den Vim-Pil
Oder ich spreche nicht mit dir
Vim ist einfach der beste Editor
Ich denke, nein? Gute Begriffe?
Hide und Seecrease
Similarly als다고 gesagt
Khan
최근
Ich historicalise
baş
wires
G dé
os
Wipp
So
H
W questo
...
D
E bauen. Kann man, muss man aber nicht. Und ansonsten rein zum Text editieren, wenn man
sich so ein paar Sachen merkt, ist Vim sehr angenehm.
Ja, Spacemax kenne ich, das ist mit Evil Bindings, ja. Das heißt in Emacs wirklich
so. Es gibt in Emacs einen Vim Emulator, der nennt sich Evil. Damit kannst du quasi,
da hast du neben Vim den besten Vim Emulator. Aber Emacs ist eh out. Ganz ehrlich, Sidewish
Studio Code und Javascript erweiterbar ist. Vergiss Emacs.
Ich will es nennen, mach deine Leben effizienter. Zehn Finger Typen. Ich habe ein Hobby, ja.
Die coolen Leute sagen ja immer, man muss mit seinen Fingern permanent auf der Home
Row stayen, dass man effektiv ist. Was die Leute irgendwie nicht so ganz beachten ist
und wo mich auch noch keiner vom Gegenteil überzeugen konnte, ist, dass du in der heutigen
Zeit eigentlich mindestens die Hälfte der Zeit im Browser verbringst. Als zu tippen.
Also keiner. Ich meine ernsthaft, gibt es irgendjemanden, der von euch so programmiert?
So, also nicht Notepack. Ich meine so. So nach dem Motto aha, okay, okay, okay, ich
bin am tippen, ich bin am tippen, alles klar. Niemand programmiert so. Also es ist nicht
wirklich so, es ist wahnsinnig wichtig, dass du ne halbe Sekunde schneller mit deinen Fingern
auf der Taste bist. In Wirklichkeit, in Wirklichkeit programmierst du so. Vor, i, in. Lass mal
kurz überlegen. Was auch immer. Ich will jetzt gucken, dass das kleiner Fünf ist. Das
ist so programmiert eigentlich eher ein Notepad schon mal gar nicht. Und nachdem man permanent,
wenn man mit zwei Händen bedienen will zwischen Maus und Tastatur wechselt, weil man eben
einen Browser braucht, bin ich das nicht so sinnvoll. Kann man machen, aber ich finde
Browser Bedienung mit Tastatur ist eklig. Ich habe das auch probiert. Ne, mag ich nicht.
Also du brauchst die Maus. Website navigieren mit Tastatur ist kacke. Ich kenne diese Geschichten.
Ich kenne die Addons. Ich kenne die Addons, wo du dann z.B. F drückst und dann Links
Highlights bekommst und sowas. Das ist nice, aber versuch mal beispielsweise auf YouTube
darauf zu navigieren. Das ist was anderes. Die Leute haben sehr spezifische Anforderungen.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum sie C++ verwenden. Nicht, weil sie es geil finden. Competitive
Programming, da verstehe ich, warum die Leute C++ verwenden und ich verstehe, warum die
Leute WIM verwenden. Da bist du aber auch nicht alle zwei Minuten am Google nach irgendwas.
Die Leute haben sehr spezifische Anforderungen. Das ist auch immer der gleiche Kram. Mehr
oder weniger. Also das verstehe ich, aber ansonsten im täglichen Einsatz bist du 50%
Browser, 50% Rest. Wie gesagt, das kann ich auch verstehen, wenn das besonders guten Support
dafür bietet, warum nicht? Aber normalerweise diese Sachen mit, du musst dein ganzes Leben
in WIM stayen und immer auf der Home-Ro und so ist in der heutigen Zeit blödsinnig.
Bei 50% der Zeit, wo man im Browser rumhängt.
Of course, I have a plant very fast. Everybody needs to learn WIM. What is school? We should learn WIM instead of school. This is how I got, you know, whatever. We can go through the docs. Text manipulation, text manipulation continued, social engineering. The entire alphabet is a command. It just changes your life, your productivity. It will be painful at first and painful at last. Good. You need WIM to become a true software engineer. Hacker? No, I don't use that.
I don't use this term. I sit all day, look at the window. Yes, it's fun. Yeah, what? What is fun? Right? No, evergreen skill. You don't really need a career once you know WIM. WIM is your career now. What's a career anyway? Lightning speed. Shortcuts. No more mouse. No more mice. No more traps. Hands stay on the keyboard. Light and portable. WIM is always there. No, seriously, you can't de-install it without breaking your computer. No need to relearn IDEs if you get fired often.
Well, actually, I don't have a GUI on my computer. Once you go WIM, you can... Terminal only. Terminal only. Brauchen wir nicht.
I'll go back. Also, ich meine, wer möchte überhaupt schon X starten? You use it on remote servers anyway. You might as well just use WIM all the time. Insert mode, visual mode. J-O-M-K-J-K. And suddenly, you just become good at it.
Let me give you a small command overview. So, WIM, you just need to learn it. It opens the door to wasting more time in WIM. Sure, it might take one year to learn the basics, but it's worth it if you ask me or anyone who uses WIM.
I'm not saying your IDE is bad, but it's pretty bad. You don't change WIM. WIM changes you. If you're using a computer and you're not using WIM, that's pretty ridiculous.
WIM is just a text edit. The shortcuts are a secret. Good. Gotta do a bit more digging. I don't recommend anyone to learning WIM. I enforce it on them peacefully with code.
Between us, I didn't really want to do this interview. It changes the way you look at it and the way you look. I gained 20 pounds after I learned all the commands and I lost 20 after I started using it.
You're wasting time if you're not learning WIM. You don't have to learn WIM. You must. Well, WIM actually feels quite natural to people who use WIM.
First time I used WIM, I was like, whoa, I can automate my CI. Now I'm like, whoa, I can automate my CI. And we don't need Neuralink. We already have WIM.
WIM is like an extension of the human brain. You need to learn WIM if you're using a computer. It's like using a car without a car. If you're using a computer, you're kind of already using WIM.
So, so. You will know then. And it's not just for code. You can use WIM for many things. I use it for everything.
Going to the grocery store, watching watches, going to the watch store or whatever stores are out there, haven't left the basement in a while.
WIM is so beyond.
Ja, das ist eher der Emacs Nutzer, oder? Der alles in Emacs macht.
WIM bindings represent things I want to do in my head.
Die Frage ist ja auch, Chet, WIM vs. Neo WIM?
Pokemon.
Manually?
Automatically.
Once you start using WIM, it's like you acquired the ring in Lord of the Rings.
You get the analogy, right?
You start changing files, changing text files, changing system registry, breaking your computer, repairing it.
Noobs don't use WIM.
I don't even have a mouse.
What do you mean you don't have time to learn WIM?
What do you have time for? Inefficient working? Inefficient work? Inefficient lifestyle? Whatever.
It opens the door for you, doing other things on the command line.
Extendable. Custom. Custom. Shell integration. Grab. Grab. Grab.
Coding isn't just about editing code. It's about editing things that are not code.
System files, READMEs, environment files, notes, mails, commit messages, lots of things.
And WIM can do a lot of different things.
You can watch everything in WIM, if you know how to.
WIM can do all the operations it can do.
Plus, plus more. Very powerful. Images, videos, binary files.
Yes.
Let me give you an analogy here. You know what an analogy is, right?
The same way car enthusiasts like to work on their own cars, programmers like editors that they can program.
Woah! Alter! Meine Augen!
Oh god. I thought I've gone crazy.
MonkaS!
Woodface!
Meine Augen!
Ich denk's dir an, denk's dir an nichts Böses.
Richtig Flashbang, ja.
Hätte Epilepsie-Warnung vor das Video machen müssen.
Die aktive Rückentwicklung der Drucker.
Lass mich raten.
Es spielt auf diesen Vorfall an, der letztens in den News war, dass Druckerhersteller Drucker deaktiviert haben von Leuten, die ihr Abo nicht bezahlt haben.
Hat das jemand mitbekommen?
Drucker deaktiviert.
Einige Apps sind Drucker, das meine ich.
Einige Apps sind Drucker wegen eines Fehlers abgeschaltet.
Es gibt ein Abo für Monats-Tinte, warum man auch immer dazu ein Abo braucht, keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum ein Drucker überhaupt abgeschaltet wird.
Ich mein, wenn die Tinte leer ist, dann ist halt die Tinte leer.
Ihr müsst euch das jetzt mal vorstellen.
Sollte eine monatliche Rate mehrfach nicht vom Konto abgebucht werden können, sperrt
Epson nicht nur die Tintenpatrone, sondern den gesamten Drucker.
Wer holt sich denn so ein?
Da ist ja DRM von Film und Musik ein Witz dagegen.
Das ist richtig Hardcore-DRM.
Mehr DRM geht nicht.
Der Drucker geht einfach nicht mehr an.
Also das ist wirklich absolut, absolut lächerlich.
Kannst du da Drucker deaktivieren?
So guck mal, ich vermute darauf spielt er an.
Müssen wir uns mal anschauen.
Es gibt kiloweise Forschungen zu der Aussage, früher war alles besser.
Früher war alles, das meiste, nicht mal alles, das meiste war früher anders.
Ob es besser war, kann man sich drüber streiten.
Es gibt bestimmt Punkte, die waren früher besser und Punkte, die waren früher schlecht,
das war anders.
Das davon entromantisiert die selektive Erinnerung an die Welt von gestern und zeigt, dass diese
Aussage in den meisten Fällen Ergebnis eines Trugschlusses ist.
Bis auf eine Ausnahme, Drucker.
Es bedarf etwas gut als jemand, der was mit Medien macht und studiert hat, um voller Inbrunst
sagen zu können, nein, dieser Herausforderung bin ich nicht gewachsen.
Vor einem Jahr habe ich nach dem letzten Kauf eines Druckers beschlossen, dieser Industrie
vollumfänglich den Rücken zu kehren.
Drucker, ganz ehrlich, ich habe seit bestimmt 10 Jahren oder so jetzt den gleichen Drucker
mit Fake-Tinte von irgendeinem Fake-Tinten-Shop und das wird auch der letzte Drucker sein,
wenn der nicht auseinanderfällt, den ich mir kaufe.
Sollte ich mir jemals wieder einen Drucker kaufen, dann wahrscheinlich einen gebrauchten
Laser.
Ja.
Das ist ein Multifunktionsgerät, deswegen habe ich mir das damals gekauft.
Das hat sogar noch ein Fax drin, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, so alt ist das.
Scanner, Drucker, Fax, ja gut, dementsprechend auch Kopierer, das erschließt sich automatisch
aus den Dingern.
Fax.
Da sind die Toner teuer, ja dafür reicht das dann erstmal lange.
Was ich habe, ich habe ein Epson Stylus Office, Moment, Epson Stylus Office BX 635 FWD steht
da drauf.
Das Ding hier, griffiger Produktnamen oder, wann kam denn der raus, Apfel-Tinten, Apfel-Tinten,
ist das schlecht übersetzt oder was?
Test, wir gucken einfach mal, ob es einen Test gab, 2012, ja 10 Jahre sag ich doch.
So und da kriegt man bei Amazon Fake-Tinte relativ günstig für so Zeug hier, 16 Patronen
XXL 20 Euro, davon habe ich noch keine Ahnung, 20 in der Schublade oder so, also nicht die,
die ich jetzt gezeigt habe, sondern so Fake-Tinte, so schauen wir uns das Video mal an.
Mein eigener Drucker wieder einsatzbereit zu machen, war schlicht höher, als das Haus
zu verlassen und das Dokument einfach woanders ausdrucken zu lassen.
Tauchen wir also ab in die perfiden Gefilder eines Gewerbes, das die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken
hat.
Zugegeben, es war vielleicht etwas überambitioniert, als ich mir vor etwas über einem Jahr extra
einen Drucker gekauft habe, als ich die Kündigung meiner letzten Wohnung losschicken wollte.
Zuvor bin ich gute 10 Jahre ausgekommen, ohne auch nur einmal einen halbwegs modernen Drucker
bedienen zu müssen.
Und nachvollziehbarer Weise habe ich angenommen, dass innerhalb dieser Fake-Tinte trocknet genauso
aus wie die echte Tinte.
Du musst erstmal, wenn du das Ding anmachst, nach einem Jahr erstmal Düsenreinigung machen.
10 Jahre, in denen Fernseher immer dünner, Smartphones immer kompetenter und Google
Glass ist der nächste heiße Scheiß wurden, diese technologischen Revolutionen auch Auswirkung
auf die Branche der Drucker gehabt haben müssen, doch weit gefehlt.
Es gab zwar technische Entwicklungen, die doch nicht um die Funktionalität zu erweitern,
zu optimieren oder gar, nur Rauchmelder, glaubt es kaum, dafür zu sorgen, dass sie zuverlässiger
werden.
Nein, sondern nur, um mit noch weniger Leistung trotzdem noch denselben Betrag verlangen zu
können.
Aber fangen wir vorne an.
Die Tinte für Drucker wäre, wenn sie Champagner wäre, der siebt teuerste der Welt.
Im Ernst, Leute zahlen für diesen Traubensaft aus dem Sodastream weniger, als für das bisschen
Flüssigkeit, mit dem sie eine E-Mail analogisieren.
Es ist aktuell teurer als Insulin, Quecksilber oder menschliches Blut.
Über die Jahre sind bei gleichbleibendem Preis die Flüssigkeitsmengen in Tintenpatronen
immer weiter nach unten gewandert.
Während man vor ein paar Jahren noch 20 Milliliter...
Das war aber früher ähnlich.
Da haben sie den Trick gemacht, dass du den Drucker gekauft hast und du willst ja mit
dem Drucker drucken.
Das heißt, es ist immer eine Tintenpatrone dabei.
Und der Trick damals war, die Drucker, die du dir gekauft hast für 80 Euro, so Schnäppchen
und Angebote, die hatten immer nur so, keine Ahnung, Viertel bis Hälfte gefüllte Tintenpatrone,
sodass du mega schnell dir Nachschub kaufen musst.
Und die Tintenpatrone hat dann halt 40, 50 Euro gekostet und der Drucker nur 80.
Also da weiß man genau, wo die Kohle herkommt.
Pro Patrone für knapp 20 Euro bekam, sind es heute meist nur dreieinhalb Milliliter.
Der Witz, oder?
Es ist weniger als der Saft einer Weintraube.
Und diese Patronen sind ja nicht gerade klein, neben den generösen dreieinhalb Millilitern
Tinte kauft man hauptsächlich einen kaum ergonomischen Plastikklumpen, dem in nur ein
paar Wochen Fische im Ozean ausweichen müssen.
Ein Liter reine Drucker Tinte kostet so über 5000 Euro, die Herstellungskosten sind aber
gleichgeblieben.
Die liegen nach wie vor bei 20 bis 40 Euro pro Liter.
Ja, ich meine, kann ja auch nicht viel sein, was das zum Herstellen kostet.
Weiter, Tinte wird also teilweise für das 250-fache Rechstab.
Aber aus was besteht Drucker Tinte?
Wasser und irgendwelche Pigment-Dinger?
Keine Ahnung, wie man Drucker Tinte herstellt, aber das kann jetzt nicht super krasse raketenwissenschaftliche
Pifat-Technologie sein.
Kauft.
Leute glauben, Bitcoin macht sie reich.
In einem Test von Consumer Reports aus dem Jahr 2018 kam zudem heraus, dass oft mehr
als die Hälfte einer Druckerpatrone für die Pflegemaßnahmen des Druckers draufgehen.
Das Drucken von Testseiten, das Reinigen von Druckköpfen oder, wie es bei meinem Drucker
der Fall war, dass man sich seine Anleitung mit den mitgelieferten Patronen doch gleich
selbst ausdrucken kann.
Warum druckt man überhaupt Anleitung auch?
Doch HP, Lexmark, Canon und so weiter werden beteuern, dass sie auch viel Geld in die Entwicklung
der Patronen stecken und dass man ja nicht nur die Flüssigkeit, sondern auch die Technik
kauft.
Und das kann man ihnen auch guten Gewissens glauben.
Nur profitiert die Kundschaft nicht von diesen technologischen Entwicklungen, denn sie sind
einzig und allein dafür da, um dem Drucker den eigenen Tintenbestand mitzuteilen und
viel zu früh die Arbeit niederzulegen, selbst wenn noch mehrere Dutzend Seiten gedruckt
werden können.
Ja, das ist auch was, das ist auch was, was mich nervt.
Also das ist tatsächlich was, was früher anders war.
Du konntest früher auch mit einem Drucker drucken, wenn die Patronen leer waren.
Dann ist halt einfach eine weiße Seite rausgekommen.
Heute mein Drucker, den ich hab, der druckt erst gar nicht mehr, wenn die Patrone leer
ist.
Er sagt einfach nö, mach ich nicht.
Wenn er meint, dass die Patrone leer ist.
Unbefinden sind zudem auch eine Art Ausweis, damit der Drucker weiß, dass man auch die
hauseigenen, wahnsinnig überteuerten Patronen nutzt und nicht etwa die, die vielleicht
kann man Drucker flashen, vielleicht manche ja, aber die meisten wohl eher nicht.
Nicht für das 250-Wache, sondern vielleicht nur für das 50-Wache weiterverkauft werden.
Je nachdem, wie modern der Drucker ist, legt er bei eingebautem Drittanbieterpatronen einfach
direkt die Arbeit nieder oder einem nahe doch nochmal darüber nachzudenken, denn sonst
elischt ganz schnell die Produktgarantie.
Gilt es noch als Nostalgie, wenn ich mich in eine Zeit zurückwünsche, in der ich einfach
ein klobiges, beiges Gerät mit einem dicken Kabel in einen dicken Laptop...
Es gab früher auch noch diese Variante, dass du Original-Tintenpatronen verwendet hast,
die man nachfüllen konnte.
Da hattest du dann so eine kleine Spritze dabei und konntest sie nachfüllen und sowas.
Das war äußerst fuddelige Angelegenheit, weiß ich, ob das schon mal einer gemacht hat
von euch.
Abraham musste, um mir die Bastelanleitung fürs Räucherhaus aus dem Löwenzahn-Adventskalender
auszudrucken.
Damals hat das wenigstens funktioniert.
Zu diesem ganzen Debakel gibt es ein fantastisches Video von Orson McConnell, der das Geschäft
mit Tintenpatronen noch tiefer seziert.
Doch das war's noch nicht.
Ich bin Opfer des sogenannten Buyers High.
Mir fällt es schwer, ein Produkt, das ich gerade gekauft habe, kritisch zu bewerten.
Zu laut ist der Teil meines Gehirns, der versucht, meine eben getätigte Entscheidung zu rechtfertigen.
Aber auch das hat Grenzen.
Als ich meinen Drucker eingerichtet habe, ist dieser Teil meines Gehirns sehr schnell
verstummt.
Nicht nur brauchte ich eine Companion-App für meinen Drucker, weil natürlich die Kommunikation
über hauseigene WLAN mit dem Computer nicht funktionieren wollte.
Nein, ich musste mir auch extra einen Account beim Hersteller anlegen, damit ich die im Drucker
verbaute Scan-Funktion nutzen konnte.
Wirklich?
WTF?
Also mein Drucker konnte ich WLAN einrichten, direkt über das On-Screen-Display und ich
kann sogar übers Web-Interface scannen und so.
Das ist doch nicht denjenigen Ernst.
Auch, aber das sollte niemanden wirklich überraschen, Hinweise darauf, dass die erzwungene oder
zumindest starken Anreiz gestellte Account-Erstellung und zwangsläufige ständige Internetverbindung
eines modernen Druckers auch dafür genutzt wird, die hauseigenen Dokumente als Daten
zu erheben, zu speichern und gegebenenfalls zu verkaufen.
Genau.
Das will ich gar nicht.
Mein Drucker, mein Drucker braucht keine Internetverbindung beziehungsweise ich will
auch kein Account oder keine App oder sowas.
WTF?
...Garniert mit künstlicher Obsoleszenz auf Steroiden.
Und dann hab ich mich etwas belesen, von dem Razer and Blades Modell gehört, nachdem ähnlich
wie bei Rasierern Drucker mit Verlust verkauft werden und das eigentliche Geld mit den Patronen
beziehungsweise den Rasierklingen gemacht wird.
Also hab ich die nächstbeste Entscheidung getroffen, ich habe nie auch nur eine Tintenpatrone
nachgekauft und Tintenstrahldruckern ein Leben lang abgeschworen und mir so eingeredet vielleicht
einen kleinen Unterschied zu machen.
Vielleicht wirds irgendwann Zeit für einen Laser oder LED Drucker, aber aktuell bin ich
fürs erste damit zufrieden, wenn ich für die wenigen Briefe, die ich schreibe, kurz
in einen Copyshop laufen muss, in dem Leute dafür bezahlt werden, sich mit Druckern herumzuschlagen.
Aber Tintenstrahldrucker sind, so komisch das auch klingt, zu modern geworden, um sie
noch sinnvoll als Privatperson zu nutzen.
Da ist tatsächlich was dran, ja.
Und das ist furchtbar schade.
LED Drucker, ja das ist wohl irgendwas modernes als Alternative zu Lasertrucker, fragt mich
nicht, keine Ahnung.
Viele Leute haben Tintendrucker, weil sie Multifunktionsgeräte haben.
Und so wie es sich bei ihm angehört hat, hat er ja auch ein Multifunktionsgerät.
Du brauchst einen Scanner oder willst einen Scanner und sagst ja einen Drucker, ok dann
kaufst du halt ein Multifunktionsgerät.
Aber das ist halt wirklich echt lächerlich.
Ich hab auch schon so viel Ärger mit Druckerkacke gehabt, das ist Wahnsinn.
Kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich hab das erste mal ein Video von MaxGrener, da war ich elf, jetzt bin ich 23.
Weißt du was das coole ist?
Das ist mir letztens aufgefallen, ich hab letztens auf Twitter geschrieben, was dazu,
ne nicht, nicht, nicht mein Ausruf von heute.
Ist mir auch letztens aufgefallen, und zwar das hier.
Also erstens, und das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle, kann ich jetzt hier auch nochmal sagen,
also ich bin jetzt seit zwölf Jahren auf YouTube, seit ungefähr zwölf Jahren so, weiß
nicht wann genau, aber seit ungefähr zwölf Jahren.
Und das musste auch erst mal hinkriegen, auf zwölf Jahre auf der Plattform zu sein,
auch viel Scheiße mitgekriegt zu haben und sonst was, aber permanent am Start gewesen
zu sein, ihr wisst was bei mir permanent bedeutet, permanent ist ja eher so ein, ab und zu mal
ja und Videos von mir bekommen immer noch 30.000 bis 90.000 Aufrufe nach zwölf Jahren
auf YouTube und was mich richtig freut ist, das hat sich hier vielleicht ein bisschen
negativ angehört, aber was mich wirklich freut ist, dass viele der Leute, die damals
die ganzen Call of Duty Videos geguckt haben, dass die heute noch am Start sind und zum
größten Teil 25 plus sind, aber das steht gut, 123 plus in dem Fall jetzt, 123 plus
ist schon heftig und was mich auch immer freut ist, wenn die Leute schreiben so nach dem Motto
Max, ohne da hatten wir heute ja sogar im Stream schon schon zwei drei, so ohne deine Videos
hätte ich nie meine Ausbildung gemacht oder ich wusste gar nicht was ich machen soll
und dank den Videos weiß ich, das freut mich, ich hab die Videos ehrlich gesagt nie so wirklich
gemacht, weil ich ernsthaft gedacht hab, dass es vielen Leuten hilft, ich will das jetzt
gar nicht so drum herum reden, so nach dem Motto, ja ich hab das nur gemacht, weil ich
Leuten helfen wollte, stimmt nicht, ich fand das Thema ganz interessant und hab mir gedacht,
da erzählst du mal was zu, aber ich hab nie die Videos gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht
hab, ja das bringt bestimmt den Leuten richtig was, da hab ich damals einfach nicht dran
gedacht, aber heute so 10 Jahre danach oder 12 Jahre danach ist mir das klar geworden,
dass das viele Leute tatsächlich influenced hat, wie man so schön sagt, ja und das ist
nice, das finde ich im Nachhinein wirklich cool.
FyFat Content, ja am Anfang halt auch mit richtig scheiß Audio Qualität, ja wirds bestimmt
auch mal wieder geben.
Die alten IT Videos wie das PSN, ja ich hab sau viele Videos gemacht, ich mein man muss
ja sagen, ich hab bestimmt auch die ein oder anderen Videothemen jetzt über 12 Jahre
betrachtet mehr oder weniger mal doppelt gemacht, irgendwie irgendwann, ja tatsächlich, ich
muss doch noch erzählen, wie mein damaliger Teamleiter Hausverbot bekommen hat, ich hab
doch ein Video gemacht hier, wo ich erzählt hab, wo sie bei uns mal einen Storage Experten
rausgeschmissen haben, das da, das da und ich sag doch in dem Video irgendwann auch,
falls ich erzählen soll, wie es mein ehemaliger Teamleiter geschafft sein Hausverbot zu bekommen,
kann ich ein Video drüber machen, das muss ich noch erzählen, ja, das muss ich noch erzählen,
da hat sie aber auch, ja hat es verkackt, ist doch auch schonmal was, wenn man weiß, was
nichts für ein ist oder, Chega, danke schön für den Sub, den Solution gibt es heute immer
noch, ja, der ist ja mittlerweile hauptsächlich auf Twitch am Start, doch gerade On-Clo, ne,
die Lösung, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich, was ich super, super beim, beim Solution finde,
warum ich mich damit auch gut, der ist genauso faul, wie ich, der sagt auch immer, er macht
was und macht es dann nicht, der Rübel, danke schön für den Sub, ja, das ist ja ewig her,
du kennst mich von alten F4 Games, ich hab mit alten F4 Games nie was gemacht,
außer abends immer Kommentare drunter geschrieben und, ach doch, er hat, er hat,
ich glaub, der hat mal, der hat mal, doch, er hat, er hat, glaub ich, mal, bei Medal of Honor,
bei Medal of Honor, glaub ich, hat er was von mir verwendet, ich weiß gar nicht,
ja, genau, genau, genau, ja, selten, selten, ja, das ist, wo der Gegner durch den Boden
gespawnt ist, oder? Medal of Honor, wo der Gegner durch den Boden gespawnt ist und mich
gekillt hat, das weiß ich heute noch, das ist ein scheiß Game gewesen, man, so richtig dumm,
richtig dumm, Alter, das war so eine Geschichte, wo sie sich damals auch gedacht haben, oh,
Call of Duty ist erfolgreich, wir bauen mal was in der Richtung, nur in, nur in noch schlechter,
ja, genau, wo der Gegner durch den Boden gespawnt ist, nö, nicht wirklich, ich hatte damals kein
Bock drauf, auf Twitch anzufangen und ich habe, ich habe auch nur auf Twitch die ersten Streams
gemacht, ähm, wegen dem Fabian, weil der hat damals öfters gestreamt und ich hab dann aber
ab und zu ja auch mit ihm, bei ihm im Stream rumgehockt und hab dann, weißt du was, mach einfach jetzt auch
einen Account, nee, das hat keinen Sinn, also es macht auch keinen Sinn sich da drüber zu ärgern,
weil ich wollte damals gar kein Twitch Zeug machen, also warum soll ich mich jetzt da drüber ärgern,
dass ich keinen Bock habe, ich mein, ich kann mich ja schlecht drüber ärgern, dass ich das gemacht
hab, was ich nicht machen wollte, so, also, dass ich das nicht gemacht hab, was ich nicht machen
wollte, naja, bescheuert sich da jetzt drüber zu ärgern. Der, übrigens der Fabian hat heute,
ähm, der hat einen neuen Job, hab ich gesehen, Twitter, der Fabian hat einen neuen Job und zwar
bei einem Tattoo Studio und da hat die irgendwie dazu überredet, jetzt ihre Tattoovier Sessions
zu streamen auf Twitch und, und heute haben sie wohl, hat er wohl irgendwie, haben sie wohl
irgendwie auch einen Stream gemacht, keine Ahnung, und der Fabian muss von ab und zu ein bisschen was
gesagt haben. Big Influencer, nee, nicht wirklich, aber ich find's halt noch cool, wie die Entwicklung
so ist. Das liegt aber auch daran, also Twitch, Twitch selbst ist ja auch schon eine ganze Weile
alt, also Twitch ist bestimmt auch schon zehn Jahre oder so, Twitch, das war mal JustinTV,
Wikipedia, ja, 2011, gibt's auch schon zehn Jahre. Habt ihr euch mal in echt getroffen,
den Fabian ja klar, wir kennen uns in echt. Ja, aber das, also dazu mal Twitch muss man halt sagen,
Twitch hat halt von Anfang an das richtig gemacht mit Livestreams und die hatten das Glück,
dass so Plattformen wie YouTube es nicht geschneit haben, wie man gute Streaming macht und immer
noch nicht geschneit haben. Ich war letztens in einem Video auf YouTube, bei ihm hier, war ich
letztens auf YouTube und war im Live-Chat von diesem Video. Wie kann man sich den Chat einblenden
lassen? Hallo, liebe. Geht das nicht mal? Kann man nicht mal Chatreplay machen oder so? Hier,
Chatreplay. Ja, irgendwo bin ich hier, guck mal. Hier, Pog, ich war der Erste, der reingespammt hat.
So, und ich habe festgestellt, dass man die Channel-Membership-Emoves auf YouTube kann
man nicht auf anderen Channels im Chat verwenden. Was ist das denn? Wozu gibt es denn Channel-Emoves
überhaupt? Ich wollte Wupp-Pog-Emoves schreiben, aber das ging nicht. Richtig hängen geblieben,
richtig hängen geblieben. Also YouTube hat es nie richtig gecheckt und hat es bis heute nicht
gecheckt, wie man ordentliche Streaming macht und Twitch hat es von Anfang an richtig gemacht.
Deswegen hat es Twitch in zehn Jahren auch geschaffen, spätestens seit der Amazon-Übernahme
E. Und ja, es gibt viel Kritik an Twitch, gerade das nicht sehr einheitliche Auslegen ihrer
Regeln. Also es gibt da schon viel Kritik, es gibt da auch schon durchaus berechtigte Kritik,
aber im Großen und Ganzen muss ich sagen, finde ich, macht das Twitch nicht schlecht und ich finde
auch nicht, dass Twitch deutlich schlechter geworden ist durch die Übernahme von Amazon,
weil ganz ernsthaft Amazon Prime hat sicherlich bei vielen Streamern, die nicht ultra groß sind,
dafür gesorgt, dass sie von neben können, was vorher nicht möglich war. Prime-Subs dürften
einen riesen Teil der Subscriptions ausmachen bei vielen Streamern. Und damit du von Subs und
allem drum herum leben kannst, diese Möglichkeit hatten sicherlich nicht so viele wie jetzt nach
Amazon Prime. Also ja und die Amazon-Infrastruktur kommt natürlich auch noch dabei. Also insgesamt
gibt es sicherlich Kritik an Twitch und da ist auch viel Spielraum nach oben, gerade was Regeln und
Auslegung der Sache angeht. Aber insgesamt ist Twitch wirklich nicht schlecht. Also ich muss sagen,
es ist nach wie vor die beste Streaming-Plattform, die es gibt. Es hat auch seinen Grund, dass sich
da nie was anderes durchgesetzt hat. Die anderen haben es entweder nicht verstanden oder waren
einfach dann viel zu spät und nicht so viel besser im Vergleich zu Twitch, als dass es sich
durchgesetzt hätte. Wie ist das letzte Ding, was versucht hat Twitch-Konkurrenz zu machen mit Ninja
Mixer? Mixer, ja, genau. Da hat sogar Microsoft gesehen, das Ding ist ein Fass ohne Boden. Das
kostet nur Geld und bringt nichts. Auf Mixer haben zu Primetime irgendwie in der Top-Kategorie keine
Ahnung 300 Leute gestreamt oder so. 300 Zuschauer gehabt. Das war halt ein Witz. Hab damals seine
Videos gesehen, jetzt wohne ich einfach selbst in Frankfurt. Ach ja, ja gut, je nachdem wo in
Frankfurt ist es vielleicht auch nicht so pock. Wenn du nicht gerade in den Bahnhaus wohnst,
ist es wahrscheinlich pock. Mixer, Alter. Nee, YouTube hat es ja bis heute nicht verstanden.
YouTube hat es bis heute nicht verstanden. Das siehst du ja alleine schon hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Das siehst du allein schon an diesem Abfuck-Chat. Ja, was soll das sein? Das ist doch kein Chat.
Da war der Knudels-Chat besser oder was es noch früher alles gab. Das hier sieht aus,
wie eine JavaScript-Übung jemanden, der gerade angefangen hat, HTML und JavaScript zu programmieren.
So nach dem Motto, Diff, Append, Diff, Append, Append, Append. Das ist doch Müll.
Da war ICQ um Längen besser, ja. Das auf jeden Fall. Wisst ihr was das beste an ICQ war? Weiß
nicht, ob das noch jemand kennt. Sumo, Sumo Volleyball. Kennt noch jemand von euch Sumo Volleyball?
Bestes ICQ? Nein, nein, nein. Was ist das denn? ICQ. Das da. Das da, Sumo Volleyball. Das war das beste an ICQ.
Das war echt so ein doofes Mini-Spiel. WTF? Was bin ich da sehend? Sumo Volleyball. Aller
Beste. Ja, wahrscheinlich war das auf Flash-Basis. Stimmt, es gibt ja Facebook-Gaming gibt es auch
noch. Warte mal, Facebook-Moment. Wie viele Leute gucken da gerade so? Facebook-Gaming ist auch so
ein Crap. Die streamen PUBG-Mobile und so Zeug. Guckt euch den Müll mal an. PUBG-Mobile. Mobile
Legends. Garena Free Fire. Was zum Teufel? WTF? So ernst zu nehmen, die Games sind sonstwo.
Facebook-Gaming. Ich fasse es nicht. Na gut, Facebook ist eh so ein Ding, wo ich keine Ahnung
habe, wer Facebook überhaupt noch verwendet. Wer verwendet? Jetzt mal Leute, meine Frage an
euch, die die Facebook-Profile haben, wie viele verwenden die noch aktiv? Alex, danke für den
Zap. Ich hatte mir ja auch mal eins gemacht für die, wie viele Max-FPS gibt es eigentlich
hier auf Facebook. 2018, doch. Vier Jahre erst her, da ich da das letzte gepostet habe. Eine
Runde, alle auf Cookies geflatet mit den Gamescom-Passen. Nee, das stimmt. Die checken
nichts. Nee. Also ganz ehrlich, Dislikes deaktivieren ist reiner, aber komplett alleiniger
Stonks-Move gewesen. Das hat nichts mit Viewer-Zufriedenheit, Content-Creator-Zufriedenheit
oder sonst was zu tun. Reine Stonks-Entscheidung, dass du nicht mehr sehen kannst, dass Videos
scheiße sind und im Zweifelsfall länger guckst. Ja und auch vielleicht dafür, dass du Werbekunden
mehr glücklich machst, reine Stonks-Entscheidung. Wie viele Zuschauer braucht man im Shit, um
davon leben zu können, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man mindestens 1.500 zum Import 500. Puh,
das ist schwer zu sagen. Das hängt ein bisschen, also das hängt von ganz vielen Faktoren ab.
Also ich kann bei weitem nicht leben davon, muss ich mal dazu sagen. Ich mach viel zu
wenig Content, ich bin viel zu wenig live, ich hab viel zu wenig Subscriber, ich mach
auf YouTube zu wenig. Also ich könnte da nicht von leben. Aber ich mein, ich mach den Kram
jetzt seit Jahrzehnten, könnte man sagen, auch gerade auf YouTube. Also ich würde mal
sagen, das ist von mehreren Faktoren abhängig. Und zwar, das erste ist, wie oft. Wie oft
machst du was? Also sprich, wie viele Subscriber hast du denn wirklich bei 500 Zuschauern?
Wenn du sagen wir mal täglich streamst, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 Stunden, oder was weiß ich, täglich,
täglich, zweitäglich, regelmäßig, sagen wir mal viermal die Woche, vier, fünfmal
die Woche, vier, fünfmal die Woche streamen mit deinen 500 Zuschauern, dann hast du wahrscheinlich
irgendwie keine Ahnung. Ich sag jetzt mal 2000 Subscriber. So über den Daumen gepilet
vielleicht, ja. Wenn überhaupt. So, und da hast du bestimmt noch keinen special Twitch-Vertrag,
also bleibt dir von 2000 Subscribern ungefähr 4000 Euro irgendwie in dem Dreh übrig. Davon
musst du Steuern bezahlen und alles andere machen, was du so machen musst. Damit würdest
du irgendwie über die Runde kommen. Allerdings denke ich, dass 2000 Subscriber bei 500 Zuschauern
im Durchschnitt wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen viel sind. Also je nachdem, ja, wie engaged
die alle sind und wie viel Content du machst, weil ich merke, dass bei mir, wenn ich viel
streame, so im Dezember, wo ich teilweise täglich streame, habe ich dreimal so viele Subscriber
wie jetzt. So, und sagen wir mal 1000, da wird es dann schon ein bisschen eng. Aber dazu kommt
natürlich noch, dass Twitch-Subscriber zwar was relativ stabiles sind, wo du dann mit
rechnen kannst, weil von heute auf morgen kündigen, das ist wie bei MMOs, kündigen
nicht alle Subscriber ihr Abo, aber so richtig fett Kohle kannst du natürlich noch mit irgendwelchen
zusätzlichen Placements machen. Von Monster-Energie-Trinks bis hast du nicht gesehen, was es auch sonst
da noch für alle Sponsors gibt. Beste Sponsoring hat immer noch Dance Gaming, der im Stream
immer so eine heiße Tasche aus der Mikrowelle gefuttert hat. So ein Sponsoring würde ich
mir auch nehmen, würde ich auch machen. Wenn irgendeine Hersteller zu mir kommt und sagt
Futter im Stream eine Pizza von uns und sag was dazu, wäre ich sofort dabei. Hot Pocket
genau Erbsenraube, so eine heiße Tasche hat er gefuttert. Weil dir sieht man das nicht,
ist kein Problem, das lässt sich einrichten. Dann machen wir Essen-Cam, das ist kein Problem,
das kriege ich hin. Wir machen Technik-Bastel-Cam auch ab und zu. Sowas, sowas würde ich auch
gleich machen. So und wenn du da ein paar ganz gute Deals hast, eventuell noch ein paar
dauerhafte Sponsorship-Geschichten von, muss natürlich zu dem Bereich passen, wo du aktiv
bist, ich sag jetzt mal ein paar Sachen, von Logitech bis Elgato bis Steel-Series, was
auch immer, was es nicht alles gibt, was die Sachen sponsoren. Dann kannst du wahrscheinlich
mit dieser Anzahl über die Runden kommen, aber du machst sicherlich keine großen Sprünge.
Vor Amazon Prime wäre das undenkbar gewesen. Wusstest du, dass es noch MSN Premium gibt?
Nee, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es MSN Premiums jemals gegeben hat. Das ist Wobbly Wobbly
in Trash? Ah nee nee nee, Wobbly Wobbly kenne ich auch. Nee nee nee, Wobbly Wobbly war
was anderes. Ja, Wobbly Wobbly kennen wahrscheinlich die meisten auch noch. Wobbly Wobbly konntest
du nicht übers Netz springen. Das war ja bei Sumo Volleyball grad das beste. Ja, Facebook
ist eh lost. Hast du das mitbekommen mit Video Adblock für Twitch, dass der Typ seinen Amazon
Reflink darüber eingebettet hat? Nein, was denn? Wie wer, wie wo? Ach es gab nen Addon
oder was, was Video Adblock für Twitch hieß und der Typ hat einen Amazon Reflink eingebettet.
Tja, muss man sehen wo man bleibt. Levelcap streamt auf Facebook. Ja, weiß nicht was
mit dem verkehrt ist. Raid Shadow Legends. Oh je, moderieren möchte ich auf Facebook
wirklich nicht. Hallo, ich hab da mal eine Frage. Kann man Browser Games irgendwie als
App machen? Ja, wahrscheinlich sogar relativ easy. Also, muss man jetzt genaueres wissen,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es relativ easy. Hab ich keine Ahnung von, kann ich nix zu sagen.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es ein GTA Abo gibt. GTA und GTA Roleplay geht auch voll an mir
vorbei. Habt ihr mitbekommen, M-Core? M-Core wurde auch gehackt, aber hat seinen Account
wieder. M-Core. Äh, nein. Das ist, das ist nicht. Das da meine ich. WTF? Ich wusste
gar nicht, dass der mal LOL gespielt hat. Okay, great. Äh, das meine ich. Nur der Name
ist immer noch, ist immer noch fake. Sein Account wurde gehackt und da haben irgendwelche
Krypto-Leute, haben irgendwelche Krypto-Leute, äh, äh, Scamsachen advertised. Ja, da wollte
es Krypto-Scamasen, genau. Gucken, ob die Leute was in den Comments geschrieben haben.
Er müsste ein Video machen, so nach dem Motto, mein Account war gehackt, dass die Leute wissen,
was los ist. Ähm, der hat es mittlerweile wiederbekommen. Ja, das hat man ja bei dem
Twitch-League gesehen. Dass da viele Leute, so nach dem Motto, ihr Traum, ich werde krasser
Streamer, dass das nix wird. Übrigens, ey. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Ich schaue ja auf
YouTube zur Entspannung ab und zu mal, muss ich jetzt, ich hab letztens einen Fehler gemacht.
Ja, ich hab letztens einen Fehler gemacht. Ich schaue auf YouTube zur Entspannung ab und
zu mal ein paar ASMR-Videos. Tatsächlich zum größten Teil von Männern. Aber auch die
ein oder anderen Mädels. Und ich hab letztens mal Just For Fun geguckt, wie viele Only-Fans-Accounts
haben. Und ich würde sagen, von der gesamten YouTube-ASMR-Damenwelt haben bestimmt 50%
Only-Fans. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, gut, mal sieht man, mit was man alles Kohle verdienen
kann. Und jetzt kommt der Hit. Wusstet ihr, dass, ähm, wie schreibt man die? Amoran?
Irgendwie, wie schreibt man die dann? Amoran? Ah, hier. Dass die Blizzard-Aktien gekauft
hat. Die hat zwei Millionen. Die hat zwei Millionen Activision-Aktien gekauft. Nein,
nur zwei Millionen hat die Activision-Aktien gekauft. Also, ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
das Geld, was die Leute bei Only-Fans überweisen, ist jetzt bei Activision Blizzard. Ja, das
ist das, was mich draufgebracht hat, erst mal zu schauen, wie sieht's dann eigentlich
da aus auf YouTube. Und ohne Scheiß, 50%, wenn nicht sogar zwei Drittel, haben einen
Only-Fans-Account. Das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hätte nicht
gedacht, dass es so viele sind. Streamer Burnout ist aber auch real. Das, ja. Na, so krass
ist es jetzt auch wieder nicht. Wenn du eine Woche Pause machst, brauchen die Leute vielleicht
ein bisschen, bis sie das gecheckt haben. Ah, 90% sind nicht weg. Ich mein, ich mach
teilweise mal drei Wochen Pause und sind genauso viele Leute wieder da wie vorher. Vielleicht,
vielleicht zwei, drei Streams später wieder so viel wie vorher, aber. Also, ganz so krass
ist es nicht. Aber ja, ich kann mir insofern vorstellen, Leute, denen ihre Existenz am
Streamen hängt, generell am Influencer sein und Content-Creator sein, die haben deutlich
mehr Druck dahinter, Content zu produzieren, weil eben das Leben davon abhängt und vielleicht
nicht nur ihr eigenes. Und dann kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass du auch mal schnell
geburnoutet bist als Streamer. Das verstehen Boomer nicht. Ich hab's so oft schon gelesen,
auch auf Twitter und auch Reallife gehört. Leute, die sagen so nach dem Motto, was, Lull?
Leute, die können den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen, den ganzen Tag spielen, die können
hier machen da was. Ha, so ein Leben hätte ich auch gerne, na, das ist doch überhaupt
kein Problem. Das ist alles Schwachsinn. Die Leute haben keine Ahnung, wovon sie sprechen.
Die Leute haben keinen Plastenschimmer, wovon sie sprechen.
Ich hab grad den Chat verloren auf dem zweiten Bildschirm irgendwie. Moment. So. Ne, die
haben keinen Plan, die sind planlos. Was, also, das haben manche Leute erzählen. Ach doch,
das würd ich so gar nicht sagen. Also gerade auf Twitch, wenn du was unterhaltsam machst,
du hast immer ein bisschen Leute, die hängen bleiben. Ähm, vielleicht auch Leute, die
ein bisschen hängen geblieben sind. Aber das passt dann meistens zum Streamer. Ähm,
aber eine Sache ist, äh, gerade auf Twitch finde ich relativ desent, was sich auf Twitch
interessieren muss als, als, als Streamer. Das sag nicht ich, das ist eine Weisheit,
die mal, ich glaub, irgendwann dense Gaming in einem Stream abgelassen hat. Wo ich mir
aber schon eine Weile, wo ich, wo ich mir schon öfters Gedanken drüber gemacht hab,
hab mir gedacht, der hat eigentlich recht. Der hat gesagt, hauptsächlich, also das Wichtigste
ist erst mal, dass man sich klar drüber wird, wer seine Stammzuschauer sind. Und so diese
Sachen mit, heute ist irgendwie mal ein neues Game, da guckt mal einer rein, der ist danach
wieder weg und kommt nie wieder, das hast du immer. Aber so, so den Kern der Leute, auf
die kommt's an. Die sind auch immer da. Und da hat er nicht unrecht. Also ich denke, wenn
du permanent versuchst auf allen Hochzeiten zu tanzen auf Twitch, dann funktioniert das
nicht. Also ich mein, wenn du jetzt Let's Player bist, dann ist ja klar, dass du öfters
mal unterschiedliche Spiele machst. Aber du kannst, glaub ich, da bist du immer noch
in der Let's Play Kategorie. Aber ich stell's mir zum Beispiel schwierig vor. Sagen wir
mal, du bist Valorant, Overwatch, CS oder sonst was Pro oder muss ja kein Pro sein.
Guter Spieler. Und die Leute gucken dir da zu für deine CS-Skills und danach sagst du,
ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf CS, ich spiel jetzt. Immer. Dota. Und bist du auch gut?
Das werden aber, da haben 95% keinen Bock drauf. Ja, hab ich auch schon bekommen. Alles,
alles schon. NordVPN möchte, mochte nicht. Wir waren uns mit NordVPN fast schon mal einig,
Leute. Das hab ich, glaub ich, schon mal erzählt. Wir waren uns mit NordVPN fast schon mal einig
für ein Placement, sowohl auf Twitch als auch auf YouTube. Und auf einmal sagt der
Typ von NordVPN doch. Max, wir haben bei dir auf dem Kanal folgendes Video gefunden. Kannst
du das löschen? Ich sag nee. Lösch ich nicht. Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich darauf eingehen,
dass VPNs tatsächlich für Vorteile haben und ich kann, wenn ihr wollt, auch das Video
thematisieren, inwieweit sich das unterscheidet. Aber löschen werde ich keinem. Das werde
ich auch nie machen. Ich werde nie Videos für irgendwelche Placements und Sachen löschen.
Als ich damals ganz, ganz, ganz am Anfang, so am Anfang ist das noch gar nicht gewesen,
also als ich schon ein bisschen größer war auf YouTube, mal was mit Activation gemacht
hab, da haben die mich auch gefragt, ob ich ein besonders kritisches Activation Video
löschen würde. Hab ich auch nicht gemacht. Ich lösche keine Videos für, nur weil es
irgendjemandem nicht gefällt. Zumal der Typ sich garantiert das Video gar nicht angehört
hat, weil sogar in dem Video selbst kam zur Sprache, bei welchen Fällen ein VPN sinnvoll
sein kann. Aber, und das ist auch so, dass die VPN-Anbieter wissentlich Sachen nicht
so klar stellen, wie es sein müsste oder sogar absichtlich was anderes behaupten.
Das ist Krunker oder Krunker oder so, wie man es ausspricht. Zum Beispiel, dass VPN-Anbieter
behaupten, dass der Traffic quasi verschlüsselt wäre zwischen, also nee, das muss ich anders
sagen. VPN-Anbieter behaupten, niemand könne deinen Traffic mitlesen, nur weil du einen
VPN benutzt. Das ist Schwachsinn. Das VPN geht von dir zum Anbieter. Der Weg vom Anbieter
zum Server und zurück zum VPN-Anbieter sind unverschlüsselt, wenn du nicht HTTPS verwendest.
Und das sind so Dinge, die muss man wissen, die sind wahrscheinlich jedem, der ein bisschen
was mit Netzwerktechnik am Hut hat, klar. Aber die meisten Leute, die irgendwelche VPN-Anbieter
Geschichten lesen, die denken dann, ach ja, sobald ich das VPN mache, ist ja alles verschlüsselt
und niemand kann irgendwo oder sonst wie was ansatzweise was mitlesen. Aber Blödsinn,
stimmt nicht. So, das Video hat ihnen nicht gefallen und deswegen wollten sie dann doch
nichts mit mir machen. Habe ich mir gar Pech gehabt. Das ist das Blatt dazu. Ach, wo der
Typ sein Ref-Link in Video-Energien für Twitch, 6.000 User has removed the source code from
GitHub and completely private. Oh, das ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen. Dann hat das
wahrscheinlich ein wenig China-Chinesen verkauft oder so. Ja, na geil. Ja. Da würde ich mir
immer Gedanken machen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich so wenig wie möglich Browser Add-ons
verwende. Das ist das beste GIF auf ganz Twitch, Alter. So geil. Ja, Twitch macht das sehr
geschickt. DNS-Adblocker funktionen auf Twitch prinzipiell nicht, weil Videos, Streams, Content
und Werbung vom gleichen Server ausgeliefert werden. Aber so Sachen hier könnten das eigentlich.
Aber natürlich ist das immer ein Wettlauf zwischen den Anbietern und den Adblock-Anbietern.
Das ist eine Playlist mit Top 100 Mario Songs of All Time. Big Stonks, easy. Glaub ich dir
sofort. No cuppa. Vielleicht Rubel oder so. Oder türkische Lira oder was? Gibt es da
sonst noch so viele tolle Währungen? Wie ändern die überhaupt den Namen vom Kanal, wenn sie
scammen wollen? Das ist relativ einfach. Wenn du Zugriff auf den Kanal hast, kannst du
neue Namen anlegen. Ich kenne auch die teilweise sehr cringe Videos von Danny Burnett. Ja,
von Danny habe ich auch ganz lange nichts mehr gehört. 25 Monate. Es wird echt mal Zeit,
dass ich mir mal neue Kekse erstellen lasse, die länger als Gold-Keks gehen mit Kette.
Habt ihr noch irgendwelche schlauen Ideen? Was könnte man denn noch machen? Der M-Kor
hat sein Account mittlerweile zum Glück wieder. Was könnte man denn noch machen? Ich meine,
ich habe einen Silber-Keks, einen Diamant-Keks, einen Gold-Diamant-Keks gibt es schon. Gucken,
ob sie einen Diamant-Keks hat. Hier, einen Diamant-Keks gibt es schon. Ich meine, man
könnte einen Keks in Diamant-Form machen, vielleicht. Der Giga-Chat-Keks. Ha, wieso?
Das finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich wüsste nicht, wie der aussehen sollte, aber der Giga-Chat-Keks,
das finde ich eine gute Sache. Dark Matter-Keks. Rolex-Keks. Leute, das ist viel zu detailliert
mit Rolex-Keks. Guck mal, wie klein die Dinger sind. Du erkennst mit Acha und Krach, dass
der Keks Gold ist und eine Goldkette hat. Noch gibt es Activision Blizzard.
sprich Browser Announce Cookie Settings. Das ist furchtbar langweilig. Ich habe
so ziemlich alles Default. Das Einzige, was ich in allen Browsern habe, ist AdBlock,
das UBlock Origin. In Chrome habe ich noch Dark Reader und ich habe FFZ für die bessere
Twitch Experience. Hier für den Stream habe ich noch, dass du die Lautstärke an den Tabs
einstellen kannst. Das hier habe ich letztens mal installiert, weil der... Alles klar. Super.
Kommt gleich wieder runter. Das ist ja richtig blöd, Alter. Sekunde. Remove. Bam. Ja, das
habe ich mir auf Anraten des Twitch-Chats installiert, weil ich so viele Tabs offen
habe. Aber hat schon wieder gesehen, ich bin halt einfach ein Many Tabs Enjoyer. So spät
noch da, ja. Aber nicht mehr lang, ich bin gleich offen. Den können wir hosten. Und Kleines
da, dem ich folge. Gibt doch Tab-Gruppen? Nein. Nein, nein, nein. Einfach Tabs. Also,
ihr müsst euch mal merken, solange man noch oben die Titel der Webseiten lesen kann, ist
prinzipiell zu wenig Tabs. So ist okay. So geht es halbwegs. Guck mal, wenn die Leiste
oben schon nicht mehr hinterherkommt, beim drüberfahren mit der Maus, dann wisst ihr,
ihr habt alles richtig gemacht. Wie viel RAM braucht Chromium gerade? Nicht viel, weil
die ganzen Tabs wahrscheinlich nicht geladen sind. Ich meine, nur 5 GB RAM. Nur 5 GB RAM
und 50.000 Threads. Nur. Das ist mehr als ich gedacht hätte. Wie viel RAM haben wir
noch frei? Leute, guck mal, die Hälfte von meinem Speicher ist noch frei. Das geht auch
nicht. Da muss man das eigentlich... Leute, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen? Äh. Moment.
Wie konnte man das noch mal, konnte man das nicht irgendwie duplizieren? Duplicate. Bam.
Schon besser. Schon besser. 8 GB RAM, jawoll, gib ihm. Der CPU Lüfter ist tatsächlich
angegangen gerade, ja. Äh, endlich ordentlich RAM. Jetzt, so ist das gut hier. Guck mal,
das kann man noch nicht mal. Mal gucken, ich halte jetzt mal Steuerung weh gedrückt, mal
gucken, was passiert. Oh. Gar nix. Moment, jetzt ist alles doppelt. Okay, chat, ich glaube,
es wird Zeit, ich glaube, es wird Zeit für Close Tabs to the Right. Bam. Und jetzt? 1,8
GB. Jaja, Dark Reader zieht auch. Alles klar, Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder. Ganz normal, neun, zehn, so irgendwie in dem Dreh. Schon
spät. Bis der NCO.